all right good morning
all right are we ready for the jury
today or do we have any preliminary
matters
okay if you want to approach with the
exhibits
which ones do you have for me
okay what number
936
all right are we ready for the jury
okay thank you
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right are we ready to
continue with the witness on deposition
yes your honor the remaining portion of
the deposition video of erin palladi
will uh include the questioning by
council demonstrated all right thank you
do you have any professional
responsibility to report or
document suspected physical abuse of one
of your patients
if
i am
if i witness or find out information of
domestic
or child abuse yes
and so what is that responsibility
i need to notify
um
superiors of of the information i was
provided with
when did you first meet this hurt
i believe
it was the end of
excuse me hang on one sec i have it here
i'm just looking at my nursing notes um
it looks like
august
2014.
okay so can we please pull up uh the
nursing nodes which i believe our uh
exhibit too
okay um i'd like to while we have this
document up i'd like to go through this
this section that's called
client history do you see where i'm
referring to
yes
was the information in this paragraph
self-reported to you by ms heard
i just have a quick moment to review
that and then i can answer that question
certainly thank you
so
to answer that question
i believe
this was
information given to me from misheard
i'm not positive but i can say that
anytime i refer or begin a sentence with
client states
or client reports those i can confirm
you know i i received that information
from the client
as far as in totality
i would assume most information came
from ms heard but i can't rule out that
i didn't get any information from the
treating physician in preparation either
um and i think you
um
would this information have been related
to you at that first meeting with ms
heard
this information
if if it was information i received from
dr kipper i would have had that
information
probably prior to meeting her but any
time that i said
states and i can confirm that i got that
information i would assume that it was
sometime within the first day or two of
meeting her because i usually
take a client history when i need a
client about a couple more sentences
it says
ah reports history of substance abuse
including an addiction to cocaine and
liquor
ct client reports abstaining from
cocaine for a couple years but was
unable to report exact dates do you see
that
do you see that where i'm referring to
yes i see that and that's something that
you would have written
yes
and um
this is also information
that you believe ms heard would have
reported directly to you again i don't
have specific recollection of this but i
would have to refer to my notes that
says the client reports
it so
the assumption would be made that she
provided me with that information
so it says it goes on to say ct does not
smoke cigarettes she reports consuming
one to three glasses of red wine
each day do you see that
yes
um and again this is um based off of
your nose something that misheard
reported to you correct
again i don't recall
the specifics of that i would refer
again that
in that particular sentence you're
referring to i use the verbiage of
she reports meaning ms heard reports so
i would make the assumption that she
reported that information to me
um in the time that ms heard was your
patient do you recall seeing her consume
wine
yes
is this
self-report of one to three glasses of
red wine each day consistent with your
recollection
i don't recall her
drinking
red wine every time
i saw her so i i can't confirm
that each time i saw her she would drink
one to three glasses i
i don't recall her drinking every time i
saw her
did you ever seen this hurt appear
intoxicated from drinking alcohol
i don't recall her being
intoxicated
okay so moving on to the next sentence
here it says she reports a familial
history of substance abuse
abuse both mother and father have abused
and become dependent on stimulants
methamphetamine opiates and alcohol
did i read that correctly
yes
and the the she here it refers to miss
heard
that's correct
so this is also something that has heard
reported to you as far as your votes
reflect
again i don't have specific recollection
of this uh it appears that she did
report that
but i don't remember
um so
a couple sentences later here it says
client admits to a his to history of
anxiety eating disorder attention
deficit disorder bipolar disorder
co-dependence issues and occasional
insomnia do you see that sentence
yes
and based off of this note and
specifically the language that says
client admin
you believe that this is something that
ms heard would have reported to you
as you stated because it says client
admits
i would make that assumption
um
what do you recall ms hurt saying about
her history of anxiety issues
i don't recall specifics uh
as i stated
earlier in the morning i
remember a general anxiety
with many issues
in her life
what do you recall miss her telling you
about uh code her codependence issues
i have a vague
memory of discussing
codependence issues within
previous relationships i couldn't give
you specifics on that it's
i just sort of have a
vague memory of discussing that do you
have any
non-specific
recollections of misheard being
anger
or enraged
other than that time that i spoke about
in london 2014
i didn't specifically witness
anger and rage
the next sentence here says her mood has
been
like labile is that am i pronouncing
that correct
so first of all what does that mean
emotional availability is
typically when um emotions swing on a
pendulum you know for example you may
see someone
very sad at one moment and quickly
transition to
extreme happiness um it sort of swings
from
like i said sort of a pendulum
and did you ever person in the time that
you treated miss her did you ever
personally witness this type of
emotional ability
i don't recall specifically
okay um
the next sentence says client expressed
concern to husband and dr kipper that
she's nervous about being alone while
husband is working on movie set in
london and expressed she has difficulty
dealing with feelings of insecurity and
jealousy when not in the presence of her
husband did i read that right
yes
um
do you um
recall learning this during your um
initial meeting with michael
i don't recall
learning this during the
initial
meeting
but again the
when i initially met ms heard and mr
depp
it was
fairly brief because then after that we
traveled
to london
um so
i don't recall if i learned of this
instantaneously or if that was
gathered you know throughout the next
day or two spending time with her
um
is this description of misheard having
feelings of insecurity and jealousy when
not in the presence of mr depp is that
consistent with your recollection
when you are treating ms hurt
i wouldn't say all the time
that was an issue uh
i have a
vague sense of those issues popping up
throughout the years but i wouldn't say
that that was a constant theme
but you do have recollections of that
being an issue at some time
while you were treating her i would say
that's a fair statement
please go to the um entry for august 29
2014.
okay so in this note i'd like to direct
your attention to this section that
starts with 2345
and specifically the first sentence it
says client rn and wrn went to dinner
together you see that
you do
um
and wrn is is debbie lloyd is that
correct
um
i'm going down a couple sentences here
it says
client verbalizes feelings of confusion
as she feels fiance would like her to
decrease flash eliminate acting career
and stay home
do you see that
do you remember having this specific
conversation with miss herd
i don't remember specifically but i do
have a general
recollection
no i don't recall specifics
did you ever have any um discussions
with mr depp concerning
um
acting career
i have a
sort of big
general
memory of discussing that before
as to specific details i
don't think i can provide you with
specifics but
it sounds familiar
did you ever have the impression that mr
depp wanted miss her to stop her and her
acting career
i don't recall that
being a sentiment
let's uh if we could scroll down to the
entry for september 2nd 2014.
um
now i'd like to direct your attention to
a sentence in the middle of this entry
it says rn and ct discuss
ct's history and current relationship
ct reports difficulty with jealousy
issues and anxiety around fiance's fame
and ability to interact with females
often
do i read that correctly
and that's a note that you wrote correct
um do you recall miss heard
um
expressing the sentiment to you again
like we discussed earlier i don't recall
that specifically i do have a general
sense
of jealousy anxiety issues popping up
throughout the years
but i don't remember that
that specific
discussion to give you anything
deeper than that
let's move on to the entry for september
4 2014.
[Music]
now i'd like to direct your attention to
this is also in the middle um it says
cta dinner with rn at 2100 at restaurant
go ahead i'm sorry okay
um ct became frustrated with wage staff
over miscommunication
ct calmly repeated herself to staff to
resolve the issue
ct expressed frustration over conflict
to rn
rn reflected change in coping mechanisms
as ct's previous coping skills involved
impulsive anger and yelling did i read
that correctly
yes
do you recall this incident at all
i wouldn't have said that i remembered
this
in preparation for the deposition when i
was re-reading through these notes i
have sort of a vague memory
of this
but i think my
my notes here probably are more specific
than what i exactly remember
um let's actually go to the entropy for
september 21st 2014 and i
um
yes okay um
please take a moment and review this and
um once you're done
um
the question is is it does this note um
reflect that incident in in london that
you just referred to
i answer your question
yes
that
is what i'm referring to
[Music]
um it says down here at the bottom of
the notes uh client's fiance offered a
promotional support
um
is that accurate to your recollection
you don't recall i would have to refer
to
my nursing note because
it's probably a lot more reliable than
my current memory
um i believe you testified earlier
though that you recall that mr depp was
present on this occasion is that right
that's correct
now we can move on to the entry for
september 22nd
okay so this note begins
um
does this
this
strike that um this starts with
is that one o'clock in the morning on
september 22nd
yeah that's correct okay
um
[Music]
are i notified that client requires
assistance
upon arrival client noted to appear
irritable loud
and angry
client screaming at times and appears
agitated
um
clients crying and state she got into a
verbal argument with fiance after
our end departure
does this reply refresh your
recollection at all about
um
it's heard having a um
an outburst
i don't know that it
refreshes my memory i would say it
reflects
my memory
is this this is the same outburst in
london that you have been previously
referring to
yes that's correct
um
do you recall anything about what the
fight between mr depp and miss herb was
about that's reflected in this note
i don't really recall i
i remember a general sense of misheard
being
very upset that her phone was hacked
because there was very
sensitive information that was leaked
from it
and i feel like there was a
she was having a difficult time
calming after that
so
[Music]
what there was any verbal um
disagreements i would assume it's in
relation to that but i i just don't
remember the specifics of
what that disagreement was
about
okay
it says here
state she feels beyonce did not provide
support to ryan did i read that right
yeah
okay
is that consistent with your
recollection
i didn't recall that but again i would
state that
my notes are
much more reliable than my current
memory and i think that probably speaks
to your previous question
um let's please um
those who be
entries which uh from march 7 2015 which
are on page
with the base number 1695
now i think we looked at these entries
earlier
do you recall that
yes
um now with respect to the entry for
march 7 2015
um
it says a client notifies rn via text of
increasing anxiety
reports emotional ability
um
do you recall with her reporting why she
was feeling anxious at this time
no i don't recall
the specific reason of
why she is ex
notifying me of that at this time
is this so it says here that she
notified you via text right right
directing your attention to the next
note for march 8th 2015.
um
and
i know you discussed this with adam
earlier so i won't
belabor this too much um
but um do you recall that this at the
time of this entry on march 8 2015 miss
heard was in
australia
i would make that assumption based upon
my
note for march 8th um i state that
client will be returning to los angeles
accompanied by house manager ben
i'm paraphrasing there but uh
yes i i believe she was coming from
australia for this particular entry
it says here aren't plans to make client
upon arrival
do you see that
oh yes yes i do um and i think you
testified to this earlier you did see
miss heard the next day when she arrived
back in los angeles is that correct
that's correct if you look at the entry
for march 9th
i refer to
meeting her
and her friends so yes i would have met
her
in person that day
do you recall how long you spent with
miss hurt that following day
i don't recall my
notes states that i met her for dinner
at 2200 which military time would be 10
p.m
i don't recall how long i was with her
so i would assume a couple hours but
again that i'm just making an assumption
um
do you recall observing any injuries to
miss her when she when you saw her on
march 9th 2015. no i don't recall i
don't
i don't make
note of it but i
don't recall either
um if is miss heard have had
visible injuries is that something that
you would have documented in your
nursing notes
i would assume
so
you uh recall miss heard seeking any
medical treatment from you when you saw
her on march 9 2015.
i don't recall
um
isn't this hurt had sought medical
treatment from you on that date is that
something you would have documented in
your notes
perhaps if there were
requests for medical treatment
that
differed from
sort of day-to-day status then yes i
might have put it in my notes if i
hadn't discussed with dr kipper but
i
i don't make any um
reference to it in this particular note
could we please pull up
what should be
um in
i think i would have uploaded as
document b
it's uh it bears the beats numbers
pilate
zero one three
four fourteen
um
i think we covered this before but just
to confirm um
is this your email up at the top that
says aaronvoram hotmail.com
i'm sorry did you respond
yes oh great thank you i'm sorry i
didn't hear that um okay i'd like to
direct your attention down to this email
from
david kipper on march 9th 2015.
that starts off erin
love you too much
do you recognize this email
leave
i believe i produced this in
reference to
the subpoena
do you recall receiving this email
i don't
recall
but i do remember
reviewing this i don't think i reviewed
it in preparation for today but probably
at the time of um
the document requested i think i
probably reviewed this
um
directing your attention to the middle
of the email do you see where it says
um
i'm sure jb will let her know we are
coming home i want her to please
not see him for a few days until we can
get him organized with the hand surgeon
and get his meds balanced
you see that yeah
okay and jd refers to mr death in this
instance
yes and the her is misheard
yes
uh did you have an understanding at the
time as to why
dr kipper didn't want miss heard to see
mr depp for a few days
i don't recall exactly
this
might have
been in
reference to australia when they
meaning mr depp and ms heard uh were
separated
i would have to check the dates on that
um
i
well
returning back to your notes where miss
herb was returning from
march uh from australia on march 9 2015
is that oriental
yes yes thank you yeah that would be the
same time period okay
um
um
and you alluded to an understanding that
dr kipper wanted mr depp and miss heard
separated
yes
and
[Music]
why why did you what was your
understanding as to why they should be
separated
i don't recall specifics um
i wasn't present in australia at that
time
i just remember
a general sense of
a
big argument happening and
the
treatment team deciding that they should
not be
around each other so
ms heard returned to
los angeles
and mr depp stayed in australia
for how long i
i don't recall
connection here says um please use the
excuse that dr kipper insists that jd
stay quiet without any distraction for
the rest of the week while we get his
medication organized balance none of
this will be accepted by her but i will
be very upset you can tell her this if
there is any stress created by a visit
that's premature do you see that
yes
um
do you have any understanding as to why
dr kipper was
directing you to provide this excuse to
miss her
again just the general sense that there
was a major argument in
australia which i wasn't present for
and separating because um because of
that
did you have any understanding as to why
dr kipper stated that none of this will
be accepted by ms heard
i would be speculating on that but
you know we we used joking terminology
based on your uh experience treating ms
heard at this time in march of 2015
um
would you agree
or did you agree with dr kipper that
miss heard would not
um
accept
not seeing mr depp for a period of time
i don't know specifically i
as i think we talked about much earlier
this morning
there was
generally a sense of
arguing reconciling and that sort of
cycle happening frequently throughout
their relationship
if we could please go back to the
nursing nodes which are exhibit two
um
could we please go back to the um
entries from march 2015 that are on the
page with the page number one six nine
five two
now we covered this earlier but um it
says in in your march 9 2015
entry
it says client states you would like to
discuss recent events between her and
husband with rn in private tomorrow do
you see that
yes i do
directing your attention to
the entry for march 10 2015.
um it says rn
met client at home at 1600. does that
um refresh your recollection that you
did meet with her the next day
no it doesn't refresh my recollection
however i would refer to my nursing
account do you have any reason to doubt
that these uh notes are accurate
no
do you recall what
their misheard
showed any injuries to you on that at
that time
oh i don't recall any
knee injuries
okay
um can we go back to
exhibit two which is the nursing notes
and specifically
um the entry for
um
march 25th 2015. just go back up to the
top of this entry for march 25th
and i just want to ask you about one
more part of this it says states she is
concerned about ability to trust fiance
following argument on mark march 23rd
2015
um
do you have any recollection of miss
heard expressing
um
concern about her ability to trust mr
deb
i would say i have a
generalized memory of their being as i
stated before
jealousy and anxiety issues
[Music]
including
mistrust
within the relationship
do you recall miss heard ever telling
you that she thought mr duff was um
cheating on her
no i don't recall that specifically i
just as i've said have a general sense
of
uh remembering
jealousy
being an issue
if we could um
okay i think uh do you recall talking
about
um visiting this herd of mr depp for
thanksgiving um earlier today
yes
does anything stand out on your mind as
um from that thanksgiving dinner that
you can recall
nothing really stands out other than it
was
i sort of have a general sense of it
being
a really jovial
fun
time together
do you recall how long you stayed at the
dinner
specifically i would assume
a few hours
um could we please just if we go to the
note from november this is an exhibit
two
um and then entry for november 26 2015
which is on page um
one six nine five four
goodbye
um
miss pilate directing your attention to
the entry for november 26 2015. um
you uh
looked at you recall seeing this entry
earlier today
yes and i believe you testify that this
is the entry from the thanksgiving
dinner that you spent with has heard and
mr deb
i believe it is
um
do you see in the middle where it says
um davey appeared calm and coherent
you do
um
is that accurate to your recollection of
that evening
and i don't remember that specifically
but i just remember a general sense of
it
being a
a fun happy
evening
so this
is with your recollection of that
evening
i would make that assumption
and
you have no reason to doubt the accuracy
of your your note
correct
directing your attention to the december
17th 2015 entry
um
will you just take a minute and read
this over and confirm whether
strike that um do you recall going and
visiting miss heard on december 15
excuse me december 17 2015.
i remember in so much as
my nursing notes regarding
this
night i i don't say i can't say that i
recall much more than i have here but i
i do remember visiting her
um
it says here that the client had visible
bright red blood appearing at center of
lower lip
do you see that
yes
did you um
other than the blood on this hard leg do
you recall seeing any other injuries to
her on that date
or a call other than
what i stated
um
did you examine do you recall examining
this herd's lipid fall
i don't think i examined it other than a
visual
um examination i didn't physically
examine
her
the note says here client also stated
her head is bruised and that she lost
clumps of hair in altercation rn briefly
looked at client's scalp but was unable
to visualize hematomas
client have described
is that what you wrote in your note
if you had observed the bruises or
hematomas that has heard have described
would that have been reflected in your
knowledge
i would assume but again i'm i'm not
trained in
looking for those types of injuries
which is why my note continues that i
encourage her to be seen by a
professional that is trained to do so
um can we drop down to the next page and
this is just the end portion of this
note
um
it says here um
rn reminds client to hydrate with oral
fluids and to limit abstain from alcohol
client was consuming red wine when
with rn
left but assured rn you would consume in
moderation
is is that what you wrote in your note
it is and i i believe i
uh
miss wrote there probably it should say
client was consuming red
wine
when
are in left not with
just to clarify
why would you advise miss hurt on this
occasion to limit or why why did you
advise miss hurt to limit or abstain
from alcohol on this occasion i don't
recall why i would be speaking to the
limit or abstain from alcohol on this
occasion
to confirm
based on your nursing notes you were
aware that
ms heard claimed to have been injured by
mr death in december of 2015 right
correct and you
went and actually saw her
shortly after that alleged incident
correct
not that same day but
possibly the following day i believe
and
you would on that occasion you observed
that she did she had a bloody lift
correct
right and she told you that that was a
result of
[Music]
um the altercation with mr duck right
right
if she had had um any other injuries on
that occasion
do you would you have recorded them in
your nursing homes
make that assumption based upon
my other notes that reference
the blood on her lip
and can we go back to the exhibit 2 and
the nursing notes for april 21st 2016
which
aids number 16957
where it says rn socialize with jd for
45 minutes may be appeared coherent
oriented and sociable
thought process logical and clear
do you have any reason to doubt that
that's accurate that's an accurate
description of mr depp on that date
jessica i apologize can you just use
your cursor to help me see the note that
you were just reading well it's it's um
sorry i actually don't have control of
it but it's
it's down it's down towards the middle
it says rn socialize with jd at
uh
times 45 minutes
jd appeared coherent oriented and
sociable oh yes i'm i i see it thank you
process logical and clear yeah okay um
so i'm sorry what was your question
regarding that
um
do you have any reason to doubt that
that's an accurate description of how mr
death appeared to you on
april 21st 2016.
i have no reason to doubt it i would
stand by my notes
um
you knew that mr depp was being treated
for um
substance abuse issues um by dr kipper
and
nurse deputy lloyd correct
yes
um if if mr depp had appeared
intoxicated on this occasion is that
something that you would have documented
if it had been
outwardly visible for either client i
would have made reference to that
we could go back to the nursing notes um
exhibited two please
and um if we could go down to the
entry for may 11.
[Music]
um
[Music]
now um miss body we looked at this you
looked at this
entry earlier today correct
um
directing your attention to just a
couple lines down it says
client discussed her birthday trip to
coachella music festival trip was april
22nd 2016 through april 24 2016.
client admits to illicit drug use during
the trip instead she ingested mushrooms
and mdma simultaneously
while also consuming alcohol and state
she vomited and was quote high for at
least 24 hours straight and quote do you
see that
yeah you see that did i read that
correctly
yes you did um do you recall um well
first of all um
do you recall this heard relaying this
to you
i don't recall these specifics that i
state here in the note
but i remember
sort of a conversation talking about
the trip after they had returned
and this starts out client admits to
illicit drug use so
am i correct that this is
based on these notes this is something
that's heard reported to you directly
again i don't remember these specifics
however my
usage of
client admits
uh refers to
a client reporting something to me
had been heard ever admitted to illicit
drug use to you
before this time
i believe in reference to my nursing
notes from when i
first
met her uh
he alluded to previous
substance use
it says here rn remind your client that
illicit drug use will not be tolerated
by medical staff
and that any medications or drugs that
are not prescribed can interfere and
cause adverse effects with with her
prescribed medication
client laughed and also reported using a
list of drugs mushrooms and mdma on may
9 2016 at home with a high-profile nail
appointment did i read that correctly
yes you did
um
do you recall
miss hurt
laughing in response to your
reminder about illicit drug use
no i don't recall that
in your
time caring for miss her did you ever
see mr deb physically
did you ever see miss heard
physically abuse mr death
did you ever see miss heard throw
anything at mr death
that you cared for her
i did not witness that
in
in the time that you treated her
did you ever see ms heard lose her
temper
as we talked in previously
the one incident that i can remember is
in
london
2014
yes 2014 um in regards to
being hacked and sensitive material
being leaked
um
did you ever feel that ms heard was um
hostile towards you at any time during
your treatment of her
no did you ever feel like she was
ignoring um attempts by
you to
contact her
yes i have a general memory of
often not often i should speak
of that happening happening on more than
one occasion where i would
reach out
and not
get a response um i just ever remember
feeling frustrated by that
when had you treated domestic violence
victims prior to this time
the time that i worked with them was in
nursing school um
i don't want to say this specific uh
place for confidentiality
reasons
but it was for domestic programs
victims
sort of a safe uh safe house
miss pilate do you remember
when you were treating miss heard that
at some point she had a cyst on her
eyelid
yes that sounds familiar
okay and do you remember that um you had
a procedure to have that fist removed
yes
and was that a surgical procedure to
reflection
from what i recall that was
handled at
an outpatient surgical center
other than that i don't know the details
of that
specific
process
um
do you recall whether ms heard had any
um marks around her eye after having
that procedure
i don't recall
i remember
a topical ointment being applied but i
don't recall if there were marks
on her eye or not
at this point the questioning switches
back to counsel for miss heard all right
thank you
do you say hilarity 93
okay
and and
and this is a this is another picture of
amber from may 21st 2016.
correct this is a picture of ms hurd and
amber sent you this text on may 21st
2016.
believe so based on the time stamp
and the same for this picture on the
next page amber sent you this picture of
her
correct
and the same for this page the next page
and sent you this picture of her on may
21st
when you um
go when you saw um
amber
on december 17 2015 when you you spoke
about that how long did how long were
you with her do you recall
recall i
would assume based on the fact that i
stopped by briefly
maybe an hour or two
okay did you go inside her house or were
you outside the door
from what i recall i was inside
okay the penthouse yes by the way when
you saw amber on december 17th um
was she wearing makeup or whatnot do you
recall
i don't call yeah i don't know
all right thank you
um before we get to the next witness
could i have council approach on the
plaintiffs 46.
um
all right so planus 46 is in evidence
your next witness
yes yes your honor
plaintiff calls michael spindler all
right mr spendler
yes
[Music]
do you sell him swear or for him to
testify truthfully in this case the
penalty of law i do
good morning sir good morning would you
state your name for the record
michael spindler
what where do you live
i live in the los angeles california
area
what's your occupation i'm a forensic
accountant
what do you mean by forensic accountant
well forensic accountant does accounting
work that is a bit more investigative in
nature
so it's essentially taking a look at
business records
and accounting records in connection
with some form of business issue
how long have you worked in that field
i've been a forensic accountant
full-time since 1990.
what'd you do before that before that i
spent about 10 years doing auditing of
financial statements
can you describe your educational
background
yes i graduated in 1981
from the state university of new york at
albany with a bachelor of science degree
in accounting and a minor in economics
are you currently employed i am who's
your employer b riley advisory services
what's b riley advisory services
it's a national forensic accounting
boutique firm that does forensic
accounting
business valuations and appraisals
and bankruptcy and restructuring work
how long have you been employed at b
riley since january of 2015.
what did you do for work prior to b
riley
well it's a long career so i'll give you
the highlights i spent about 30 years
with national accounting firms as
partner at two different firms
and also was involved with a couple of
forensic accounting boutique firms
okay
do you hold any certifications i do
what are they
i'm a certified public accountant with
licenses from six states new york
california
arizona nevada utah and hawaii
i'm also certified in financial
forensics
i'm a certified fraud examiner
i'm accredited in business valuation and
a certified anti-money laundering
specialist
do you participate in any professional
organizations i do
what are those
well i've had leadership positions and a
couple of them i'll mention the
association of certified fraud examiners
i was the president of the los angeles
chapter and i'm currently on their board
i've been actively involved with the
california society of cpas
i was the president of the los angeles
chapter it had 11 000 members at the
time
uh was also on cal cpa council which is
kind of their board directors
and also a member of the board of
trustees
of the cal cpa education foundation
have you testified as an expert before i
have
approximately how many times about 100
times roughly
about half of that in
trials and arbitrations
what's your typical role in those cases
typically it can take a number of forms
but commonly i will testify with respect
to damages
have you done any film industry work
yes i have what was that
i've done work involving all the major
film studios i've also done work on
behalf of writers directors producers
actors studio executives
your honor i'd like to proffer mr
spindler as an expert in forensic
accounting all right any objection
all right so thank you
what work did you do in this case
well in this case i was asked to take a
look at
issues with respect to lost earnings for
mr depp
what in particular
did you do
i looked at
accounting records that were produced by
mr depp's accounting firm ed white and
company
i looked at
trial
exhibits i looked at deposition
testimony i looked at some trial
testimony
and i've looked at various other
documents and exhibits in connection
with the case
what specific period did you analyze
with respect to lost earnings
i looked at the period following the
publication of the op-ed so i looked at
the period from
december 18th
2018 through october 31st 2020.
what materials did you review
i looked at uh the accounting records
that have been produced by mr depp's
accountants
any other materials
various
deposition transcripts
trial testimony contracts etc
what conclusions did you draw from your
review
i concluded that uh mr depp uh suffered
lost earnings
of approximately 40 million dollars
how did you reach that conclusion
well there are really two main
components to that
the first relates to the loss of the
role of captain jack sparrow in the
pirate six film
so the loss relate to the loss of that
role in that franchise picture
it was 22.5 million dollars based on
testimony provided by mr jack wiggum
in addition we looked at yes
did you do anything else with respect to
pirate sex
uh well we also calculated the net
earnings that mr deb would have received
from that
okay um
and what did you base your
analysis of pirate six on
uh based on the testimony of mr jack
wiggum okay
what else did you do with respect
to
the lost earning analysis that you did
well the other main component to this is
taking a look at
all the other roles the non-franchise
films
so those
films studio films independent films and
endorsements uh that mr jeff realizes
and and enjoys
so in connection with that we looked at
his bookings for the year 2017
and by bookings i mean
instances where mr depp is hired
for a project
and
he receives that first money related to
that project in 2017. so
in other words you've got a deal
and cash showed up so it's real
so we looked at his 2017 bookings
and we
calculated for that year for that period
his bookings were about 17.5 million
dollars
the main components of that mr wiggum
testified to
we then looked at
the period of time
following the op-ed
of december 18 2018 through october 31st
2020
so if annual earnings was 17.5 million
dollars
in what is
known as a typical year
a reasonable base year
at that rate what would we have expected
mr depp to have earned
from that period of october 18th 2018
through
october 31st 2020
and we then compared that to his
bookings his actual bookings for that
period of time
why did you use 2017 as a typical base
year
well a couple of reasons first of all mr
wiggum testified that that was a typical
year
for mr depp
uh and it's also the most recent clean
year
that was experienced in 2018 yet the
publication of the op-ed that didn't
happen in 2017.
okay
did you do anything did you prepare
anything to assist the jury with respect
to the analysis that you performed we
did prepare a chart yes
your may approach all right yes sir okay
all right
thank you
you know i
think this is plaintiff exhibit 12 40.
i'm going to uh
i'm not going to move it into evidence
i'm simply just going to use it
with your permission to publish it to
the jury so that the
witness can explain it
any objection to demonstrative 1240.
all right demonstrate well um do you
have electronic copy of it okay that's
fine we do
okay
who did this chart
uh i in combination with people working
under my direction from my firm all
right
can you explain to the jury what
you've done here
sure i'd be happy to uh so as we
discussed previously
uh mr depp lost the role in pirate six
and the effect of that was lost earnings
of 22.5 million dollars based on mr
wickham's testimony
and then what we've shown here is the
ten percent agent commission
that why did you deduct 10
because that's the
rate for uh mr depp's agent
that's what his agent receives out of mr
depp's earnings
in connection with setting up a project
for mr depp
so
we deduct that 10 percent which comes to
2 million 250 dollars just ten percent
of twenty two point five million
and the net effect of that the amount
that mr depp would have received after
deducting that fee would have been
twenty million two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
and that's the first component of this
uh
what did you do in terms of the analysis
of
lost bookings for non-franchise films
okay so that's the next section of the
chart and as i mentioned before his 2017
bookings were
about 17.5 million dollars
so that rate of earnings
over the period from mid-december
through the end of october 2020 or
mid-december 2018 through the end of
october 2020
would come to about 32.8 32.9 million
dollars
but we then compared that to actual
bookings during that period of time of
mid-december 2018 through the end of
october 2020
that amount was 10 million 586
000
we deducted those bookings the actual
amounts from what we would have expected
to arrive at his lost bookings for
non-franchise activity and that comes to
about twenty two point three million
dollars and once again we've deducted
the ten percent ages commission
so the net
effect
the lost earnings to mr depp after that
agent's fee
uh four
non-pirate films comes to about 20
million dollars
what does the figure at the bottom
corner of the chart the 40 million
318 dollars and
40 million 318 237 what does that
represent well that's your grand total
that's the sum of those two components
uh for total
lost earnings
40.3 million dollars
no further questions all right
cross-examination
thank you your honor
good morning mr spindler good morning
so this
this lawsuit isn't the first time you've
worked with johnny depp is it
it is not you've worked with him in a
lawsuit that he had in the past with his
old law firm correct
yes just a little bit of work yes
and um so in this second go around this
as a paid expert for mr depp you're
you're making 550 an hour is what he's
paying you is that right
that's the amount that my firm bills i
do not receive that
now the subject matter of your
opinion testimony in this case is the
economic damages that mr depp has
allegedly suffered as a result of miss
herd's december 8 2018 op-ed correct
correct yes
and this is the first case in which
you've testified as an expert relating
to economic damages claimed by an actor
correct
first time i've testified to but i've
done that work before
and you understand that this case
is about only whether miss heard's
december 18 2018 op-ed constitutes
defamation of mr depp correct
that's my understanding and you
understand that this case isn't about
anything else misheard has ever said or
done
correct i
believe that's correct
and to be to be clear
you were testifying only
as to
alleged damages right
correct so you are not offering any
opinion or any testimony on whether
those specific damages that you just
discussed were caused by the op-ed
correct that's correct
and you're assuming for the purposes of
your report that the damages that you're
testifying about were caused by amber's
op-ed correct
yes
so you're therefore not looking into
whether
anything else that's happened with mr
depp's life or career could have caused
him economic damages correct
i believe that's generally correct yes
so you're not looking at whether the
article published in the uk in june 2018
calling mr depp a wife beater caused him
the damages correct
correct you're not looking at whether
the lawsuit that he brought in the uk
against the publisher of that article
caused him those damages right
correct you're not looking at any of the
evidence that came out in that lawsuit
about alleged instances of abuse against
amber correct
correct
you're not looking at whether the
consequences of mr depp's drug and
alcohol use have caused him the damages
you're discussing correct
correct you're not looking at whether
the worsening performance at the box
office of mr depp's movies over time has
caused him the damages that you're
testifying about correct
correct and i'm not acknowledging any of
this being accurate i'm just saying that
that wasn't part of my calculations sure
i understand i just want to want to make
clear what you didn't look at what
you're not opining on and so to to round
that out you're not considering even the
impact of amber obtaining a restraining
order in may 2016 and whether that may
have caused some damages that's not part
of your opinion correct
well since we were taking a look at lost
bookings
using 2017 as a base year
any activity that preceded that would
have been baked into those calculations
that way and we'll get to those
calculations in a minute because i'd
like to i'm going to put up the chart
that you put in your expert report
but but first i want to talk about
pirate six because that's basically the
two components of your damages is pirate
six and then this
non-franchise lost bookings right
correct so for pirate six specifically
you assume that he would have made 22
and a half million dollars on pirate six
right
correct
and you took jack wiggum's word for it
in making that assumption correct i
based it on his testimony yes now you
never saw a contract that mr depp had
for pirate six correct correct because
no contract exists to your knowledge
correct so far as i know i've not seen
one and you didn't take into
consideration jack wiggum's testimony
that disney was non-committal about mr
depp being in pirate six even before the
op-ed correct
correct
and you didn't take into consideration
the press articles that came out prior
to the op-ed that suggested that disney
had made a decision not to cast mr depp
in pirate six correct
correct
and you have no idea whether pirate six
will ever be made
right
i wouldn't know that and you have no
idea if disney has decided one way or
the other whether mr depp would be in it
or whether they'd offer him a role in it
if it is ever made correct
well my understanding is that they made
a public statement that he would not
okay and you have um
if disney decided that he wouldn't be in
it you have no idea when they decided
that correct
i know that there was a public
announcement subsequent to the
publication of the op-ed
what what public announcement are you
talking about
i believe there was an interview of mr
bailey
that was published
several days after
okay well that that interview of mr
bailey didn't didn't say that he wasn't
going to be in it in fact have you
looked at the the article
that the jury saw the headline for
yesterday dated november 5th 2020 about
mr depp potentially not being in pirate
six have you looked at that article i
assume not
no okay
um and you didn't take into account mr
depp's statement that he wouldn't do
pirate six for 300 million dollars in a
million alpacas correct
uh that sounds like hyperbole to me i
didn't take that very seriously okay
sound like somebody who was a bit hurt
or in pain so as a result of the loss of
the role so if mr depp didn't lose a
role in pirate six because of the op-ed
but he lost it for other reasons then
your damage's opinion relating to pirate
six would drop to zero dollars correct
i believe that's correct if it's not
lost for that reason if it's lost for
some other independent reason
then i think that would need to be
considered okay thank you
now let's shift gears and talk about the
non-franchise earnings for a moment um
you claim this number is about 21
million dollars right
roughly
20. we could we'll we'll pull it up um
well actually we'll
we'll look at the chart here 20 20
million dollars about 20 million dollars
after agent fees correct okay
um and to reach that number you looked
at what his historical earnings records
showed right correct
and you got that information from ed
white's
office
yes
and you assume that the information you
got from ed white's office was accurate
right
i did yes
can we please pull up
the chart that's in his expert report
your honor this is um
or mr spindler i'd like you to take a
look at this and confirm for the court
that this is the chart that's in your
expert report
if you would
it appears to be yes your honor i'd ask
for permission to publish this just as a
demonstrative
objection all right
so mr spindler
this chart shows mr depp's earnings by
year
based on the information that you
received from ed white correct
correct from 2009 to 2020
yes
and
it shows that from about 2009 to 2019
and i i
i didn't add these up visually but from
your report you say that mr debt made
about 459 million dollars
correct
correct
now
the two highest earning years in this
time period were 2010 and 2011 right yes
you see that you made about 70 million
dollars in 2010
i do yeah and then the third highest
year was
2014 right yes under 60 million and
you'd agree that from the period of 2010
to 2020 his annual income on average was
decreasing
yes but you have to take a look at the
components of this right and in 2000
just wanted to get your your agreement
that from 2010 to 2020 his annual income
was decreasing
now
in 2020
he earned more than he did in 2016
correct
on an overall basis yes and in 2020 he
earned more than he did in 2018
correct
yes just based on earnings and in 2018
and 2019 he earned an almost identical
amount correct
yes and 2019 and 2020 were both after
the publication date of the op-ed
correct
yes okay now i want to talk about some
of these non-franchise
earnings because
when i looked at your chart that was
displayed to the jury i didn't see
anything specific listed so can you just
confirm for me that you can't name a
single lost business opportunity other
than pirate six that mr depp lost as a
result of the op-ed
that's correct that's not the nature of
this
television just
if you could just just answer my
questions yes or no as best you can
please you can't identify a single
television project that mr depp
allegedly lost out on as a result of the
op-ed correct correct that's not the
name they can't identify a single
advertising campaign or marketing
opportunity that mr depp lost out on as
a result of the op-ed correct right
these are the calls so it's fair to say
that for the sit for for for the lost
opportunities that you can't name
you're assuming
as with pirate six that those
opportunities were lost because of the
op-ed correct
correct
now
you you mentioned something interesting
in your direct and in your report you
say that you use 2017
as the base year to calculate
what you claim mr depps
should have earned in 2019 and 20
correct
correct
and let's take a look at this because
2017 he made
that much
correct about 45 million or so
yes but in 2016 he made
just a shade over 20 correct
correct 2018
he made a shade under 20 right
yes same with 2019 right
correct and then 2020 he actually made
more than he had in the prior two years
or in 2016 and made about what 22 23
million or so is that right right but as
i indicated this is just based on
earnings you need to get behind right so
you said
there are a couple interesting things
you said
you said that the most recent that 2017
i want to explore why you relied on that
now first of all you you said that you
relied on jack wiggum's testimony that
2017 was a reasonable year to use
correct
correct despite the fact that 2017
he made more than twice as much as he's
made in any year over the last five
years correct
yes but when you take a look at there if
i can no no no
well i wanna i wanna get to your
thoughts because you said that one of
the reasons you used 2017 was because it
was
you you said i wrote down the most
recent clean year right correct and and
and and then i think you explained you
said because the op-ed was was written
in 2018 right
correct but the op-ed wasn't written
until december 18 2018 correct
yes so the first if 2017 was clean
then the first
352 days of 2018 were also clean weren't
they sir
if i may explain
mr wiggum testified that for the first
half of 2018
mr depp chose to take some vacation time
also he chose to go touring in the
summer with his band
and then he did a film towards the end
of 2018
with the publication of the op-ed in
december of 2018
that would have impacted the prospects
for that film that was done in 2018
so he chose to do just the one film in
2018
and then the impact of the op-ed on that
film would have meant that it was not a
clean period you could not have looked
at that film to get a good sense of what
his earnings should have been
because he didn't have the chance to
earn
box office bonuses
or private participation well
that's why 2017 is a much much better
year to use
than 2018. well let's break that up
let's break that up i think you you
let's break that down a little bit you
said that that 2017 was a much cleaner
year but isn't it also true that there
were other reasons why 2018 wasn't clean
for example the june or the april 2018
article by dan wooten calling mr depp a
wife peter correct
that did occur that year yes the june
2018 lawsuit that mr depp filed in the
uk
against the sun for calling him a wife
beater correct
yes and how about the
october
articles
reporting that disney had decided to
move on from mr death and not cast him
in pirate six correct
i'm sorry what effect would that have
had well it became before the op-ed so
it's another reason why 2018 isn't a
clean year in your mind correct
and articles no those aren't three
articles two months before the op-ed
saying that that disney decided not to
cast mr death that would also keep 2018
from being what you would call a clean
year correct
i've described the reasons why i believe
2018 was not a clean year okay
now
you're aware as we talked about that
amber's op-ed wasn't published till
december 18 2018 correct correct
so
mr depp could not have lost out on any
opportunities as a result of the op-ed
prior to december 18 2018 correct
correct and he couldn't have lost out on
any opportunities
in 2017 as a result of the op-ed
fair
fair and he couldn't have lost out on
any opportunities in 2016 as a result of
the op-ed correct
correct
and so
in in calculating your damages
you didn't you didn't use 2016
you didn't use 2018
but you chose to use 2017 correct
yes
in 2020
than he did in both 28 16 and 2018
before the op-ed was published correct
correct and that's just based on
earnings
all right redirect yeah thanks
you explained 2018
why didn't she use 2016
well first of all 2017 was a more recent
year
2017 was a year in which mr wiggum
indicated that that was a typical year
for mr depp he had a studio film he had
a
independent film he had an endorsement
deal
2016 is further back in time
as i understand it his earnings capacity
for that year would have been just about
the same or even higher than 2017
because there was an endorsement deal
that mr deb passed on that would have
been worth
a lot of money according to ms jacobs
so
2017 made the most sense
why did you ultimately use the
method that you
uh did to determine the lost earnings
because it just makes sense it's um
the correct approach to take you're
taking a look at what mr depp would have
been expected to earn in a typical year
and then you're comparing that to the
period of time
where you're analyzing
following the op-ed
from december of 2018 through october
2020.
so you're taking a look at what you
would have expected him to earn it's
very simple compared to what he actually
did earn
no further questions all right thank you
is this witness subject to recall
all right sir since you're subject to
recall do not discuss your testimony
with anybody but since you are giving
expert testimony you're free to stay
into the courtroom okay sir thank you
you have a good day thank you very much
all right happy birthday
watch your step there
all right
uh plaintiff russ is casey all right
plane of rest all right ladies and
gentlemen we're going to go ahead and
take our morning recess it may be a
little longer because i have a few uh
issues to take up with the attorneys but
then we'll proceed after that okay so
please do not talk about the case and do
not do any outside research okay
all right
well we go ahead and take our recess
till 11 45 and then i'll come back and
entertain the emotions at that time okay
is
okay
my god
but at the same time granting a motion
to strike is appropriate when the
plaintiff as as is the case here has
failed to present evidence sufficient to
create an issue of fact on his claims
and in addition the court may not draw
inferences from the evidence that defy
logic and common sense that's the austin
versus shony's case 254 virginia 134.
so the issue here your honor is a couple
fold and i'll take the statements
um well two of them in one category and
one of them in the other category but i
think we're all clear that the sole
issue here
is whether amber heard can be held
liable to mr depp for defamation arising
from the 2018 op-ed and the 2018 op-ed
alone
and to establish that mr depp has to
prove the following elements he has to
prove that the
uh the publication of the op-ed and that
it was written by ms heard
he has to prove that the statements in
the op-ed
were both false and defamatory so
falsity and that they contained a
sufficient defamatory sting and he has
to show that the statements were made
with the requisite intent in this case
actual malice on the part of amber heard
i'll save that argument till the end
your honor and i'll focus on uh the
first two at this point and because it
seems like plaintiff is proceeding under
a theory of defamation by implication
under the pendleton case 290 virginia
162
bears the burden of proving the
statements at issue were designed and
intended by ms heard to imply a
defamatory meaning designed and intended
to imply defamatory meaning
so and to satisfy those first two
elements publication and uh falsity and
defamation or defamatory nature of the
statements mr depp bears the burden of
proving that by a preponderance of the
evidence and to satisfy the requisite
intent and show that ms hurd acted with
actual malice he has a heightened
standard of proof that he must prove uh
by clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with that malice so just
want to talk about the two the the the
two statements on domestic abuse
in the op-ed
and your honor is well aware of the
ample virginia case laws talking about
how you have to view the op-ed as a
whole you have to view words in context
so these are the the statements that
that read then two years ago i became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and then the other statement that
says i had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse now those
statements are entirely opinion except
for
according to mr depp the
discussion of domestic abuse so the
statement i became a public figure
representing domestic abuse and the
statement in the second uh sentence that
mr depp was a man accused of abuse the
rest of those are inactionable opinion
statements now the evidence
adduced thus far your honor
shows that mr depp can't sustain a claim
on these for two reasons first of all
the statements are true on their face i
don't think that there's any dispute
about that and that's been the subject
of of some testimony in this case uh two
years before she wrote the op-ed miss
her did in fact become a public figure
representing domestic abuse when she
obtained a domestic violence restraining
order against mr depp and the mr depp
was indeed accused of abuse those are
facts that are true
now to the extent that mr def will argue
that he's proceeding on a defamation by
implication claim again
um
the court should grant the motion to
strike because the undisputed evidence
is that he did in fact abuse amber now
there is
there's a dispute in this case there's
ample evidence that he physically abused
amber but we acknowledge that there's a
dispute in this case on that but what
there isn't a dispute in this case is
non-physical abuse both mr death and his
expert shannon curry have testified that
abuse may come in many forms it may be
physical certainly but it may also be
verbal
maybe emotional maybe psychological
you'll recall mr depp
even kind of setting the baseline for
what abuse was when he talked about the
non-physical abuse that he allegedly
suffered at the hands of his mother he
said it was worse than the beatings and
the example he gave was that his mom
used to used to call him one eye as an
example
because he had a lazy eye i guess as a
child that was something that mr depp
himself said was abuse his mom calling
him one eye so we setting aside the
evidence of physical abuse in this case
which is already overwhelming mr depp's
claims relating to these two statements
should be stricken because
of the ample and undisputed evidence in
the record of non-physical abuse by mr
depp toward misheard there's evidence in
the record of recordings
messages including messages written in
blood
for with his finger blood and pain vile
names shouting
menacing and threatening statements
there's the video the kitchen video and
sweet sir there's the audio of him
calling miss heard
like i say numerous vile names there's
the audio of him asking to her to cut
him
and whether she wanted to be cut so
there's there's there's plenty of
evidence out of the words or out of the
mouth of the plaintiff in this case that
constitutes non-physical abuse and
misheard again under the standard set
forth by his expert and the plaintiff
himself those are far worse than his
mother calling him one eye when he was a
child in addition to that your honor
there's travis mcgivern's testimony from
yesterday in which he testified that at
a minimum on the night of march 23 2015
both parties were being verbally abusive
to each other
mr mcgivern also testified about mr depp
quote rearranging her closet throwing
racks of clothing
down onto the floor and throwing at
least one rack down the stairs now in
california property damage alone can be
a basis for getting it to a temporary
restraining order under california law
so further evidence of non-physical
abuse or non-physical toward misheard
you saw the cupboards in the sweets or
kitchen video and then dr laura anderson
your honor testified that she believed
that the parties engaged in mutual abuse
and that
at least some of the time that that was
initiated by mr death this is all
evidence we haven't gotten to put on our
case yet and to the extent this case
proceeds and that will start now but
this is all evidence that has come in
while plaintiff controls the playing
field of what evidence has come in and
he can't overcome that
in this case your honor if mr depp
abused miss heard
physically
verbally emotionally or psychologically
even one time
then she wins on those claims then she
wins it's that simple
and the evidence is overwhelming and
undisputed in the ways that i've just
described that he did
so for that reason your honor those
claims should be stricken and i'll just
cite the union of needle trades versus
jones case this is 268 virginia 512 that
states if the plaintiff does not
establish the falsity of the statement
by a preponderance of the evidence in
his case in chief he has not met his
threshold burden and the trial court
should strike the evidence and grant
summary judgment to the defendant that's
exactly what should happen here
now move on to the second issue which is
the headline containing the phrase
sexual violence that should be stricken
for a couple reasons first your honor
the evidence has established that
misheard didn't write the headline
mr doherty from the aclu that that's the
only evidence that's come in in this
case thus far
plaintiffs control the up well i
understand but there's also a
stipulation that miss hurt would not be
called in the plaintiff's case because
they would then use her testimony for
part of their case in your case right
and that's that's correct your honor
yeah i agree and that's a different
issue that i'm not arguing i'm not
arguing that the courts should strike
because they haven't put misheard on to
say to testify about the headline but i
assume part of that would be that they
would
what they i hope they i guess they
intend to get from miss herd is that she
she either wrote it or republished it
yeah what happened the next day is miss
heard posted it on her instagram account
and said look what i published yesterday
in the washington post so she adopted
the title and and her name was on the
article which contained the title and mr
ronborne the only reason i'm sorry to
know
the only only because i know that was a
stipulation so it's hard for me to say
that that's all the evidence for motion
to strike if there's a stipulation that
they're still going to get more evidence
in on that particular issue i think and
i'm happy to hand the court the
transcript of the april light hearing
because one of the things that we're not
arguing today is that
because they haven't put in evidence of
the i think it was a tweet but mr two
says it was instagram i don't know
whatever it was that because there was a
tweet adopting the op-ed she published a
day before in the washington post okay
all right so what i'm not arguing today
is that because they haven't gotten that
tweet into evidence or had ms heard say
that she tweeted that
that we're entitled to to summary
judgment this point i'm not arguing that
but that's all that we discuss on april
8th and i'm happy to hand the transcript
up here on her and we actually never it
wasn't a stipulation it was simply an
agreement that they didn't need to call
her in their case to make that point and
then and then ms bredehoff said we'd
have to agree on the language of any
stipulation they haven't proposed
anything to us and haven't gotten back
to us so
i think that that's only relevant we're
not basing our request for for for
motion strike here
on misheard
not having testify to sending that tweet
but you're saying for the motion to
strike the only evidence before the
court is that the washington post wrote
that title correct and that's a that's
that's very different from what happened
the next day there's
the stipulation didn't go toward who
wrote the title that was never part of
anything and it's undisputed and
misheard will testify that she didn't
write the title well i understand that
but yeah but i think not undisputed your
honor i apologize for interrupting okay
but i i think the issue is that whether
it was republication well and i'll so
that i'll get to that next i know but to
see the problem is how do i do a motion
strike when that evidence isn't before
me yet well the republication isn't
so so the evidence that's before you is
that the washington post wrote the
headline or that misheard didn't and
that's the only evidence and that's not
going to change the republi the tweet
which was the only subject of the the
discussion the pre-trial conference
where
there was no stipulation it was just an
agreement that we're not going to base a
motion to strike on them not introducing
evidence of the tweet
that that was what it was i'm happy to
hand the transcript up if your honor
would like to see that but that isn't
actionable because under the lakova
versus halper case 995 f3134
retweeting a link doesn't constitute
republication now that case doesn't it
does if you add something to it but i
just don't know the evidence you honor
very quickly it's a judicial admission
they admitted in ms hurt's answer she
admitted to the tweet so that
establishes that she adopted
the op-ed in its entirety and it was
discussed we talked about judicial
admissions one was the op-ed itself the
second and this is reflected your honor
if i could finish my argument i mean i i
would appreciate
i can't wait to oppose this
go ahead go ahead
go ahead so and again we can
we we can look at the transformation you
understand my concern i do understand
your concern and i guess
what i'm saying is that there's there's
two levels one is there's no dispute and
there's not going to be a dispute that
she did not write the headline so then
you look at does is the tweet actionable
and and the argument here is that as a
matter of law
retweeting something isn't actionable
and so okay as under the lakova case 995
f3134 in that case dealt with hyperlinks
and how those aren't actionable
but to be very clear nothing that was
discussed on april 8th nothing that was
discussed at that pre-trial conference
was in any way relating to any
stipulation about who wrote the headline
it was simply that they need not call
miss hurt and their case in chief to get
her to say that she sent a certain tweet
and that tweet's not in evidence yet but
i assume that they'll try to put it in
evidence at some point but that's you
the tweet doesn't need to be an evidence
for you to strike this this claim on
that basis
so
um
even assuming
um
even assuming that the headline implied
certain conduct by mr deaf again
mr depp can't meet his burden of proof
on this
third your honor he can't prove that
miss hurd acted with actual malice
mr depp hasn't introduced evidence
sufficient to permit him to meet this
now again this is a heightened burden of
proof he has to show actual malice by
clear and convincing evidence and as the
bose corporation case from the u.s
supreme court it talks about the role of
of judges as gatekeepers of the of the
constitution of the first amendment and
uh the role of barring entry of a
judgment that's not supported by clear
and convincing proof now that case was
about a pellet review
of first amendment issues but the same
holds true for your honor here here he
hasn't introduced mr depp hasn't
introduced any evidence and there can't
be a reasonable inference drawn that
would permit a jury to find by that he's
proven by clear and convincing evidence
that miss heard wrote the words with
actual malice and again we go back to
the testimony of mr dougherty which is
was their witness they put him in and mr
dougherty the only evidence relating to
intent or anything relating to this
op-ed which was again
maybe mr chu will try to say that we
stipulated to mrs heard's intent on
april 8th which of course we didn't but
the only evidence
that has been presented in this case
your honor by mr daugherty was that the
op-ed wasn't misheard's idea that the
aclu asked her to write the op-ed and
and indeed that they even wrote the
first draft and then that miss heard
vetted the finished article with her
lawyers and with lawyers from the aclu
to make sure that it wasn't problematic
that is the only evidence in the record
and on that evidence there cannot be a
conclusion that misheard acted with the
actual malice that's necessary
particularly when you consider the
heightened burden of proof
so reviewing the op-ed as a whole with
the court acting in its appropriate
function as a gatekeeper of the first
amendment
we ask that that the court strike
plaintiff's evidence
and award summary judgment to misheard
either in whole or in part thank you all
right thank you yes sir
morning your honor may please the court
bench you for plaintiff johnny depp it's
just still mourning um your honor if i
may approach
all
right thank you thank you
i've just handed to mr rottenborn in
your honor in opposition that we
prepared before we had the benefit of
seeing
miss herd's affirmative motion to strike
but i think we've anticipated
the arguments made such as they are
the court should deny defendant amber
heard's motion to strike because
mr depp has come forward in his case in
chief with multiple credible witnesses
documents
and authentic tape recordings of ms
heard herself
not only satisfying all of the requisite
elements of his claim for defamation
including actual malice
but also going the extra mile of showing
that miss hearn
physically abused him she's the abuser
in this courtroom
your honor going back to the standard
as your honor is well aware and
considering a motion to strike the trial
court must view the evidence and all
reasonable inferences drawn from the
evidence and light of the most in the
light
most favorable to the plaintiff
any reasonable doubt as to whether the
plaintiff has produced sufficient
evidence
of the wrong alleged must be resolved in
the plaintiff's favor and the motion to
strike denied unquote and that's the
boeing case i believe mr rottenborn
referred to
243 virginia 81 at 81 1992.
quote the weight and credibility of the
testimony of witnesses are solely
matters for the jury the jury may accept
that part of the testimony it believes
and reject that which it does not
it is also within the exclusive province
of the jury to draw any reasonable
inferences from the evidence before it
citing rate versus minix
275 virginia 579 at 5.85
in deference and respect to the court's
time mr depp incorporates by reference
the legal analysis set forth in the
court's opinion letter dated march 27
2020
overruling ms herds demurra to the three
defamatory statements at issue and that
letter opinion is attached as exhibit
one to mr def's opposition
that's where the court uh fulfilled its
proper gatekeeping
role that mr rottenborn referred to
as a threshold matter
the elements of a defamation claim are
the following publication
of an actionable statement with the
requisite intent citing the shaker
versus fault case 290 virginia 81 at 91.
as to damages they are presumed here
because ms hurd's false allegations of
domestic abuse sexual assault and rape
constitute defamation per se
citing the tron field case 272 virginia
709
713 a 2006 case
as the court noted at page three of its
opinion letter
typically an editorial or op-ed column
is ordinarily not actionable because it
appears in a place devoted to or in a
manner usually thought of as
representing personal viewpoints
id however virginia recognizes that
quote a defamatory charge may be made by
inference implication or insinuation
citing the carwel case
and a statement expressing a defamatory
meaning may not be apparent on its face
citing pendleton with which the court is
quite familiar 290 virginia at 172.
accordingly in order to render words
defamatory and actionable it is not
necessary that the defamatory charge be
in direct terms but may be made
indirectly and it matters not how artful
or disguised the most modes in which the
meaning is concealed
if it is in fact defamatory carwile 196
virginia at seven
and based on the authority and reasoning
set forth in pages four through eight of
the opinion letter the three statements
at issue are actionable under a theory
of defamation by implication
mr depp established in his case in chief
that ms heard in fact made all three of
the defamatory statements at issue as
the court admitted into evidence as
plaintiff's exhibit 1 the op-ed misheard
published in her own name in the
washington post on december 18 2018
and let's take the three statements and
the proof that has been induced
statement number one amber heard quote i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
per page six of the opinion letter the
first statement could reasonably convey
the alleged defamatory meaning i.e that
mr depp abused misheard to its readers
without extending the words beyond their
ordinary and common
accep acceptation see pendleton 290
virginia at 172
also citing the carwel
case
resolving every fair inference in mr
depp's favor this statement could
reasonably imply that the sexual
violence misheard spoke up against was
in fact perpetrated by mr deb
mr depp produced several credible
witnesses and documents proving that ms
heard was implying that he committed
sexual violence against her
mr depp himself testified to that as did
his sister christy dombroski
mr depp's former agent christian carino
testified
that
as did his current
with uh current agent jack wiggum but
perhaps most convincing and of all and
most disgusting of all was the testimony
of the aclu's terence doherty a lawyer
nonetheless
mr dougherty testified
among other things
that when the op-ed when they were
pitching the op-ed to the washington
post
they stated hey michael
wondering if we might interest you in a
piece by amber heard who as you may
recall was beaten up during her brief
marriage to johnny depp
on what the incoming congress can do to
help protect women in similar situations
mr daugherty also
testified
that
everybody understood
as ms heard in the aclu clearly intended
that these this statement and the other
two statements referred directly to mr
depp quote this is an article that was
in usa today and specifically ties
amber's statement in her op-ed piece to
johnny depp
and when jessica white who actually
wrote the op-ed that miss heard later
adopted she says quote to mr daugherty
so much for not
mentioning jd when the usa today made
clear that they like everybody else who
read the op-ed understood
that as ms heard clearly intended it
referred to mr depp
which makes her instagram post two days
before the trial began
that she didn't mention mr depp all the
more outrageous
your your honor uh there is um
miss shulman also of the aclu
acknowledged that miss herd's
op-ed referred to mr depp
uh so it's very clear that the aclu and
ms heard intended that that was the
whole purpose of this so that they could
get interest in this and it would
coincide
with the premiere of aquaman because
otherwise no one would have been
interested in anything written by miss
hurt
mr daugherty also testified that
ms hurd only paid 1.3 actually she
didn't even pay all that out of the 3.5
million dollars that she had pledged to
the aclu and then they helped her lie
about it
and it's one thing your honor
for her to stiff the aclu which frankly
played a reprehensible role in this case
it's quite another for her to fail to
honor her obligation
to the children's hospital of los
angeles with sick and dying children
and that she failed to do as well
and as your honor has mentioned uh
the fact that she put her name on that
article uh means that she is responsible
for all of those statements
uh which she specifically adopted later
and i'll go through the other two
statements quickly your honor well can
we stay on this one for one moment
though
because do you agree that the only
evidence before that we've heard in this
trial as far as the title of the op-ed
is that even mr dougherty i believe
testified to it that it was something
that washington post wrote well for the
for the one
he's not our witness your honor that's a
witness from the aclu i understand it's
the only evidence i have i respectfully
disagree your honor all right what the
only real evidence your honor has is
plaintiff's exhibit one which is amber
heard putting her name on the entire
article including the title
that is the only evidence before you the
aclu was a co-conspirator with ms heard
and whether they say oh maybe the
washington post wrote it that's not the
end of the story all she has done is
create an issue of
an issue of fact as to whether she wrote
the title or not
so you're you're saying just having that
exhibit in evidence is absolutely
absolutely your honor her name is on the
article
what what does an average reader expect
so that alone is sufficient to beat
emotion to strike if they want to come
back later and say gee she didn't write
the title as if that were a defense i i
hope they make that argument i hope they
make that argument to the jury because
it's about as credible as her as her
argument that oh i wasn't referring to
to johnny depp she didn't have to
and the testimony of terence doherty was
very clear that when they took out the
references to johnny depp no one was
interested in this article anymore so
she said put it back in put it back in
make it more
spicy so people would read otherwise she
couldn't get it in the washington post
it would be back in teenage vote which
is the other
publication that was considering
publishing it because no one was
interested in what she had to say and
wish in unless she was defaming mr debt
but if i could go to the second
statement i'll try to be quicker on it
two years ago i became a public figure
representing domestic abuse and i felt
the full force of our culture's wrath
for women who speak out
as for the second statement defendant
called herself a public figure
representing domestic abuse
which can be read to imply that she
became a representative of domestic
abuse because she was abused by mr depp
not because not just because she spoke
out against alleged abuse this inference
can be drawn without extending the
language beyond its ordinary
common acceptation citing carlisle 196
virginia at
8. uh your honor quote to constitute a
publication
it is not necessary that the contents of
the writing should be made made known to
the public generally it is enough it is
said if they are made known to a single
person unquote citing snyder versus
fatherly 158 virginia 3 35 at 3 50.
everybody and his grandmother testified
that ms heard
was referring to her bogus ex party tro
that she obtained on may 27 2016 and it
was interesting that mr depp's own
lawyer
said that she wasn't even provided
notice so ms heard made
very sure
that mr depp wouldn't have notice of the
ex-party tro and miss heard herself the
evidence shows knew that mr depp having
just suffered the loss of his mother was
already on the other side of the country
was already in new york at the time of
this tiara and was heading to europe for
several weeks so she knew she didn't
need any protection from him this was
just a scam for her to get the seven
million dollars in the divorce
settlement that she said she gave to the
aclu she swore she gave to the aclu and
the children's hospital of los angeles
and she pocketed
instead
mr depp miss dimbroski mr carino
mr wiggum and the inevitable mr
authority of the aclu which lent its
once respected name
to ms heard's defamation
so while miss heard may have avoided any
direct mention of mr depp's name there
is extensive testimony and evidence in
the record showing that the implication
of her op-ed could not be more clear i.e
that mr depp abused ms hurd during the
course of their marriage
under virginia law quote it is not
necessary that the defamatory charge be
in direct terms but it may be made
indirectly and it matters not how artful
or disguised the modes in which the
meaning is concealed if it is in fact
defamatory
citing carlisle we can argue as to how
artful it was
but the implication was very clear as
the court has previously
uh
ruled or
not law of the case but as the court has
uh persuasively written in its opinion
letter
let's move to the falsity of ms hurt's
ever evolving and ever escalating change
of
ipv and sexual assault
mr depp's sworn denial is all he needs
to survive a motion to strike but
there's a lot more than that your honor
and i'll try to be brief
three police officers actually four but
the three who've testified already
officers signs hadden and gatlin
testified unequivocally that ms heard
did not have a mark on her on the
evening of may 21 2016.
uh and i i could go through uh i'll just
go through very quickly officer hadden
strike that officer melissa science on
jury trial day 10. question did you
provide a copy of this pamphlet to amber
heard answer i did not i didn't identify
her as a victim of domestic abuse the
next day officer melissa science
okay at this time did you notice any
injuries on misheard
officer science i did not
question okay were you looking to see if
she had any injuries on her at the time
officer science yes i was
question and so you were looking to see
if miss heard had any injuries and you
determined that she did not is that
accurate officer science correct
question okay and was the lighting good
enough in the hallway for you to make
that determination answer yes the
hallway was well lit
officer gatlin's testimony was the same
and he had the body cam
officer hadden's testimony was the same
the testimony of nurses debbie lloyd and
aaron buram who didn't like who like the
police officers did not work for mr da
mr dap in fact they they work for dr
kipper also belie ms herd's false
allegations of abuse
isaac baroosh and alejandro romero both
testified that they saw misheard
repeatedly and in the clear life between
may 21 2021 which was the last time
mr depp saw her before leaving on the
hollywood vampires tour the next time he
was to see her
was when miss heard begged him to come
see her in san francisco which is hardly
the act of a domestic abuse victim
so
we have isaac baruch and mr romero
saying that they saw misheard repeatedly
in the interval of time between may 21
and may 27th
when she obtained the farce x party tro
and they saw no marks on her face and no
swelling
uh two witnesses mr varus and brandon
patterson saw the video
of miss heard and her sister whitney
pantomiming the fake punch
after this alleged incident of abuse
ms heard's former personal assistant
kate james and several other witnesses
including dr
david kipper saw no violence by mr depp
and no injuries to misheard
indeed witness after witness has come
forward to testify that miss heard
far from being a domestic figure
representing domestic violence unquote
is in fact a recidivist perpetrator of
domestic violence
on mr depp and and others
we have the testimony uh the harrowing
testimony of mr depp himself
who described several witnesses
one as your honor will recall when he
was hiding in the bathroom after
escaping one of her attacks
and uh she claims to have hurt her foot
kicking the door mr depp
opens the door
to see if she's hurt and then she kicks
the door in on him and punches him
we have the incident of december 15 2015
when um
ms heard uh threw punches at him wildly
at the back and side of his head
mr depp testified that he ducked and
covered to protect his face eventually
he turned around to grab her and stop
her arms from flailing
december 15 in the bahamas during an
argument miss heard grabbed a can of
mineral spirits and threw it at mr
depp's face striking him in the forehead
bridge and nose era and the jury saw a
photograph of the brew the bridge on the
bruise of his nose
we have testimony from mr and and and by
the way tara roberts who is the manager
of the island confirmed that uh the
incident with the mineral spirits you
have mr depp's testimony of what
happened on april 22nd 2016
uh and we've heard testimony today from
aaron boren fellotti that mr depp was
very responsive
was very sociable
had not uh was not in any way inebriated
that day when miss heard says he was and
she and she attacked him that
um
she attacked him that night as well and
i'm getting to to to the end of this
your honor
we have um
we have ms heard's own admissions we
have her um
admitting
to hitting mr dapp and her only
contention was that she wasn't punching
him she was just hitting him
we have testimony from travis mcgivern
that uh missed on february 23rd 2015
misheard through and hit mr depp with a
can of red bull and then
sucker punched him with a closed fish
fist
finally we have
the rather stunning testimony of ben
king
quite a credible witness who accompanied
miss heard on the flight back from
australia
where miss hurd admits to him in a
rhetorical question quote did you ever
totally lose it on someone you love
which was we would respectfully submit
an admission
of her severing the top or the tip of mr
depp's figure a finger
finally your honor
statement number three
quote i had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse again
quoting very briefly from page seven of
the court's opinion letter quote
drawing every fair inference in
plaintiff's favor the court can fairly
include
conclude the defendant's statement that
she saw how institutions protect men
accused of abuse could reasonably convey
to its recipients that she saw how mr
depp was protected by institutions that
he abused her and spoke
up against it
uh your honor again we have multiple
testimony from multiple people including
jack wiggum and all the others mentioned
that this was
a
reference to that
um
your honor again
the the lies that have already been
exposed that ms heard has told about
the charitable contributions uh the
incidents in this case and again i'll
just cite
a couple of more uh the testimony of
isaac baroosh
when mr baroos saw miss hurd on june 3
after she'd gone through with the sham
ex-party
tro
and
mr burus was asked did she say anything
in response
and mr burus testified yeah
in response to that she meaning miss
heard
looks at me and said i told johnny i
don't want anything the lawyers are
making me do all of this and i you know
that's what she said well the lawyers
are making her do all of that
and apparently she wanted the seven
million dollars for herself she even
lied about the final insult
left on the marital bed after her 30th
birthday party
and it was quite telling that she
admitted to starling jenkins a former
united states marine
that this was a terrible prank gone awry
well she lied about that too
in fact she said mr depp was crazy to
even allege
that she could have done such a thing
well she admitted it
to
mr jenkins
per tronfield
as cited earlier mr depp
does not have to prove damages
because this is defamation per se in
fact these involve some of the most
heinous crimes any man or woman
can be accused of
however he has done so
jack wiggum tested yesterday that the
impact of the op-ed was catastrophic on
mr depp's personal and professional life
uh that it was a 22.5 million dollar
loss on uh pirate six and another 20
million on others uh we've had
the um
uh we've had the testimony oh so we have
mr wiggum testifying as to the 22 and a
half lost on pirate six and another 20
lost on the other films the other studio
films the indie films
and and the other uh the other ways mr
depp would have made income
we have richard march's testimony
douglas banya's testimony
and the testimony of
uh michael spindler just this morning
um finally your honor none of the miss
heard's affirmative defenses which would
include you know her trying to create an
issue of fact on on the title
can support a motion to strike as to
which she bears the burden of proof of
her affirmative defenses
quote whether the defendants have met
their burden cannot be resolved when
considering a motion to strike
uh sievert 243 virginia at 83.
and and just to um
respond to mr rottenborn's citation to
the lokova case which we hadn't seen
until he mentioned it today
i would only note your honor
that defendant admits that she tweeted a
link
to the online version of the op-ed at
paragraph 97 of her answer though again
the the admission of exhibit 1 is more
than enough to survive
the motion to strike and the lakova case
at 995 f third 134
holds that republishing a hyperlink
doesn't necessarily start the statute of
limitations not that a hyperlink
uh cannot be defamatory so without your
honor we respectfully request that the
court
deny the motion to strike
in full and let's hear from this hurt
thank you sir
thank you your emotion
thank you your honor i i can only assume
that mr true wrote that speech for an
audience outside the court because it
didn't really address my arguments i'm
going to focus on what our specific
arguments are for the motion to strike
your honor um mr two spent
almost 30 minutes of the court's time
talking about the the disputed evidence
of physical abuse in this case which
ms hurt hasn't even put on her case and
and um
i can tell you she's not the abuser and
if the case moves forward she and her
witnesses will put on even more evidence
of the physical abuse she suffered at
the hands of mr deb but that's not the
basis for our emotion right now your
honor he he talks about how mr deb
uh had a sworn denial
um and that that should count he he we
read his testimony he claims he didn't
strike her
but again that's not the basis for our
motion the basis for emotion is the
clear and undisputed evidence of
non-physical abuse by his definitions by
his standards by the standards of his
expert there is no dispute that mr depp
on abused amber and therefore if he did
it even one time
there is no dispute that even under
their theory of the case
the implication that they want the jury
to draw from the article which again i'm
not
arguing for the purposes of today
because under the legal standard i'm not
going to argue that i'm not going to
waste the court's time with that but
even under their standard
the undisputed evidence is that mr depp
did commit abuse against misheard and
therefore that those first two
statements were false
that's that's our argument on that as to
the headline it's funny mr chu
we played you know two or three hours of
an aclu deposition now he says well that
wasn't our witness it was his witness
your honor he just spent 10 minutes
talking about what mr doherty said and
mr doherty testified that the washington
post wrote the headline that is the only
evidence your honor i understand he says
well exhibit one has her name on it
exhibit one has her name on it but the
only evidence in this case about who
wrote that headline
is mr doherty's testimony it is
undisputed they could have put anyone
else on they could have called ms hurd
for that because that was not part of
the stipulation at the at the pre-trial
conference it was only the tweet that we
talked about your honor and they chose
not to do that now miss heard will
testify she didn't write that headline
so it wouldn't have helped them but that
they've had three weeks to put on their
case your honor they've controlled the
playing field of evidence there is no
dispute
that misheard did not write that
headline
no dispute simply saying well her name
is attached to it that can't overcome
the testimony of the aclu they call them
a co-conspirator of course mr depp chose
not to sue them
but the testimony of terence doherty
that she didn't write that headline that
takes care of the sexual violence
headline your honor and i'm not going to
take up any more of the court's time
addressing portions of mr dutt or mr mr
chew's argument that don't go to our
motion unless your honor has any
specific questions but i want to be
respectful all right thank you sir all
right for this motion i've taken the
arguments of counsel and last night i
reviewed all of the evidence that has
been submitted in this matter so as to
the second and third alleged defamatory
statements um at the motion strike at
this juncture i view the evidence the
light most favorable to the plaintiff
and reasonable inferences from the
evidence to the plaintiff and if there
is a scintilla of evidence that a
reasonable juror could weigh then the
matter survives a motion to strike
in this matter there is evidence in the
case that a jury could weigh that the
statements were made by the defendant
that the statements were about the
plaintiff that the statement was
published that the statement is false
and the defendant made the statement
knowing it to be false or the defendant
made it so recklessly as to amount to a
willful disregard for the truth
the weight of that evidence is up to the
fact finder so the motion to strike is
denied as the statement two and three uh
the motion to strike as a statement one
i'm going to take under advisement
because
if it's not a stipulation i'm not sure
what it is but there seems to be an
agreement that the tweet of misheard is
part of the plaintiff's evidence which
is not in evidence at this point so i
can't rule on that statement whether or
not it is just a tweet or if it's some
sort of republication or something i
don't know because i haven't seen it yet
so as to the motion to strike on on
statement one i'm going to take an
advisement because ruling out now it
would be premature because i just don't
have that evidence in the case okay
thank you very much all right since it's
12 30 we don't need one just take lunch
uh go ahead and let the jurors go to
lunch and come back at 1 30. does that
sound okay
okay
all right do you want to do it now
okay sure
all right
anything further
one thirty more courses three less than
130. all right
all right thank you
yes oh you have another oh perfect thank
you
all right that's 1804
all right thank you
and you want to approach on the other
issue
or yes
all right are we ready for the jury
okay
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
all right be seated all right the
plaintiff has rested in the defense case
your your witness your honor i'd like to
call dr don hughes to the stand dr
hughes
a penalty of law
good afternoon
thank your honor
will you please state your name
dawn hughes
and what is your profession
i am a clinical and forensic
psychologist and where is your practice
located
i practice in new york city
what is a clinical psychologist
sure so a clinical psychologist is
somebody who assesses evaluates and
treats individuals who are suffering
from a variety of ailments or problems
that they have in their lives it could
be a major psychiatric disorder and it
could be problems in living
clinical psychologists also participate
in training in education and in research
ventures
and what is a forensic psychologist
so a forensic psychologist is someone
who applies the science and principles
of clinical psychologists to a
particular legal question at hand
and please describe your background in
terms of your education plea of course
so i received my bachelor degree in
psychology from hamilton college which
is in upstate new york i then received
my master's degree and my phd from nova
southeastern university which is in
florida
i then had to complete my year-long
internship and that was at yale
university in the school of medicine in
the department of psychiatry and there i
did two full year rotations i did a year
rotation in the substance abuse
treatment unit and another year rotation
in the west haven mental health clinic
where we saw
individuals suffering from a wide array
of difficulties and psychiatric
illnesses
after that i had to complete my
post-doctoral fellowship which is
another year that's required in order to
get licensed and that was back in new
york at cornell medical college in the
anxiety and traumatic stress program
there
please describe your training and
experience in psychology and trauma
so my experience in trauma has been
predominantly throughout graduate school
i
started at a domestic violence program
that was housed within our community
mental health center of the university
and that program we saw both men and
women who were coming through the
program the majority of the men were
court-ordered for
batterers intervention programs to
participate in mostly group therapy
because of their behavior in intimate
partner violence domestic violence we
also
treated the female victims who were
victims of intimate partner violence and
mostly in individual therapy but we did
run some groups there as well
after that practicum experience i went
to work at the veterans administration
in their outpatient psychiatry clinic
in that clinic i treated
mostly
this was florida so they're much older
adults so we saw a lot of vietnam era
veterans and actually world war ii
veterans
in that program and a few of um veterans
who served combat in the first
iraq war
sort of overlapping in that time i also
was the research coordinator for the
child sex abuse survivors program and
that was also a treatment program that
was housed within that same community
mental health center
and we saw individuals both men and
women who were coming for treatment
to deal with the consequences the
psychological after effects of having
been sexually abused as a child
um after that i completed my internship
when i was at yale at the substance
abuse program because we know there's a
high concordance a high rate of
trauma-based disorders with substance
abuse i
put together a group a women's group of
female heroin addicts recovering heroin
addicts who also had either domestic
violence or childhood abuse histories so
we did a dual substance abuse harm
reduction model with the
uh
the healing from the traumatic effects
of of the violence that they experienced
on my postdoctoral fellowship i was in
the anxiety and traumatic stress program
as the name
sounds we saw individuals who were
suffering from trauma-based disorders
and anxiety mostly late adolescents and
adults
men and women from rape sexual assault
violence some were simple assaults on
the streets being mugged and things of
that nature
i also did teaching and training for
victim services which is new york city's
largest
victim-based organization who runs a lot
of services for
victims of domestic violence and
shelter-based programs and i did the
some education and training for them for
on teaching for a number of years
thank you let's talk about your current
occupation what positions do you
currently hold
so i currently have a private practice
in in manhattan
and i also have a faculty position at
weill cornell medical college i'm a
clinical assistant professor of
psychology in the department of
psychiatry there this is what we call on
the voluntary faculty which means you
don't get paid
but you participate in bringing in the
interns selecting the interns for that
year
in that program i teach
i think for the past
seven eight years the ethics seminar to
the interns and also participate in
other didactics that they have i'm also
called upon
to
sort of troubleshoot difficult scenarios
that clinicians either trainees or full
blood clinicians might have
if there's an issue of intimate partner
violence or child sex abuse and they
don't really know sort of what to do in
that situation i get consulted to do
that
and then most recently i was part of our
program's covert response team where in
pretty much march april may june july
2020 where new york city was the
epicenter we um sort of mobilize them
we're really doing psychological first
aid and helping our um our
hospital-based workers um deal with the
stress and the trauma from seeing so
much death and destruction
because of covet in in those first
months of new york city's covert wave
what does your independent practice
entail
so my independent practice is
predominantly i say three things
the bulk is i see individuals in therapy
two and a half days i see people who
come to my office who are mostly dealing
from
you know the traumatic effects of
victimization childhood abuse rape
sexual assault sexual harassment
domestic violence and i see these
individuals in therapy
i do have a percentage of individuals
who do not have a trauma history and
that's usually the anxiety disorders
that i see they may have panic disorder
or generalized anxiety disorder or other
difficulties and just relational
difficulties or problems in living
the second big part of what i do is is
this forensic psychology like i am doing
here today i evaluate individuals who
were involved in in legal matters i
consult with prosecutors and district
attorneys and u.s attorneys on their
cases
and just something that has to do with
the legal system
and then the other smaller percentage is
the engagement in in professional
activities in the profession
do you have any areas that you
specialize in
yes i specialize in interpersonal
violence and traumatic stress and what
is interpersonal violence so
interpersonal violence is the umbrella
term for when one person does something
violent or abusive toward another
and that includes domestic violence
childhood sexual abuse rape sexual
assault sexual harassment physical
assault all of those type of behaviors
we understand as interpersonal violence
and then traumatic stress is the
consequence of that what happens to
individuals when they experience these
sort of life-altering events these
really adverse life events traumatic
stress is one of the outgrowths and the
psychological consequences that people
have
when they've been exposed to these type
of traumas
so intermittent partner violence rape
and sexual assault are major areas of
your focus of practice that's fair to
say objection leading
i'll sustain the injection okay
i'll just move on what types of patients
do you treat in your private office
so i treat adults mostly
men and women in my practice i sometimes
will treat late adolescents 17 or 18 and
they'll come to me usually after
a rape or sexual assault and i'll treat
them in short-term treatment
but mostly adults who are you know have
sustained some kind of traumatic event
in their lives
approximately how many victims of
interpersonal violence have you examined
or personally interviewed over the
course of your career
hundreds upon hundreds
and how many years have you been
practicing
well i started practicing in graduate
school in 1992 and i was licensed in
1996 so 25 30 years okay are you board
certified
yes i am please describe to the jury
what board certification means and what
you are certified in
board certification is the highest
degree of postdoctoral certification
that a psychologist can obtain and i am
board certified in forensic psychology
and that means that i have just amassed
a competency in the area of forensic
psychology
and are you licensed to practice
psychology yes i am
and in how many states are you licensed
i'm licensed in three states in new york
north carolina and connecticut and then
i have some temporary licensees in other
states as well
have you published in the area of your
specialization
i have i am not predominantly a
researcher or somebody who writes i'm a
clinician i'm doing direct clinical
service
but over the course of my graduate
school and postdoctoral time i have
published some things yes
and have you published
a book chapter relating to rape and
sexual assault
overworld
yes i have rape and sexual assault in
adult women
and have you published any book chapters
relating to structured or clinical
assessment of risk or violence yes i uh
co-authored a book chapter entitled
this is a structured clinical assessment
of risk and violence okay have you given
any other trainings or presentations to
mental health professionals in the area
of trauma and abuse
yes i've given many trainings uh at
national conferences at um legal
conferences for for attorneys for mental
health professionals on understanding
trauma and how trauma may show up in the
courtroom on understanding what a victim
of intimate partner might look violence
might look like of understanding the
difficulties that a rape victim might
have to come into court to testify
and training just regular
sort of mental health professionals on
how to understand trauma how to look for
trauma what does it look like when it
comes into your office how do you treat
it how do you assess it
all of those factors i've done a number
of trainings on
have you been invited at any on any
occasions to train attorneys and judges
on trauma and violence
yes i have i was um invited by the
judicial conference to be part of the
training curriculum to train our new
york state
supreme court justices on issues of
intimate partner violence and traumatic
stress
some of the things that i've just been
talking to here about how to understand
what happens in those situations how to
understand the myths and misconceptions
that may be that may abound in these
situations and how you can sort of more
accurately understand
what a victim is talking to you about
and telling you when they come into your
courtroom
have you given any presentations to
judicial symposiums on domestic violence
yes i've also been you know contacted by
sometimes judges will have symposiums in
their courtroom they will
make a decision to hold a particular
symposium on particular topics and i was
you know asked to come to presentations
for judges on numerous occasions
and what if any uh presentations did you
do on understanding women's use of force
in ipv
um that was a recent
presentation and i think that was
invited by one of the um
one of the judges of the office on
domestic violence in new york
and the title of is when women use force
in situations of intimate violence and
my topic was to talk about the the
complexities of that issue and what does
that look like and how can we
differentiate
if both people are fighting how do we
know that this is intimate partner
violence so what are the sort of what
does the research tell us about that how
do we understand that and how can we
really accurately assess that and that
was sort of the bulk of what that
training was about
what professional organizations do you
belong to
um i belong to a number i belong to the
american psychological association which
is the largest body of psychologists
in the united states um over here
headquarters in dc i um because it's so
big there are subdivisions of the trump
of american psychological association so
i belong to the division of trauma
psychology i belong to the division of
psychology and the law the division of
psychologists and private practice
i belong to other organizations uh the
international society for traumatic
stress studies which as the name
says it's an international society where
we are interdisciplinary mostly
psychiatry and psychology researchers
and clinicians to really understand and
further our awareness about trauma and
traumatic stress i belong to the
international society for trauma and
dissociation i belong to the anxiety
disorders of association of america i'm
a fellow in the american board of
forensic psychology
i don't know if i'm forgetting any
okay
are any of these specific to
interpersonal violence or trauma
well clearly the trauma division of the
american psychological association the
international society for traumatic
stress studies and the international
society for trauma and dissociation and
then also the anxiety disorders of
association continues to talk about
trauma
because prior to this new dsm-5 it was
ptsd was originally categorized under
the anxiety disorders so there are still
colleagues and researchers in the
anxiety disorders
organizations who talk about ptsd and
trauma
do you hold any leadership roles in
these organizations
yes i am currently the president-elect
of the trauma division of the american
psychological association um that is an
elected position you have to be elected
by our membership um and now i serve uh
as with the presidential trio so there's
three of us you serve with the immediate
past president the current president and
the president-elect so it's a three-year
term and what we try to do is continue
to
disseminate best practices in trauma
psychology and also interface with the
larger american psychological
association organization to continue to
disseminate best practices and have just
a voice for trauma psychology with our
larger body and policy making
i've been involved in the trauma
psychology executive board
since its inception i was a founding
member of that division i served as a
membership chair a program chair and a
wars chair
i was the apa council of representatives
which means i was also elected to serve
a three-year term and sit on the
governance board of apa representing the
division of trauma psychology so i've
been very actively involved in the
trauma division
and what is the division of trauma
psychology
so the division of trauma psychology or
psychologists who who come together who
want to um disseminate best practices in
trauma psychology we want to make sure
that we have our finger on the pulse of
research and evidence-based
interventions for people who are
struggling with traumatic events that
have happened to them
okay
have you served in leadership positions
of other professional organizations
uh yes i was uh there's a new york
city-based organization it's called the
women's mental health consortium and
that's also an interdisciplinary
organization it's psychology psychiatry
nursing social work and this was formed
in order to
give women um sort of a referral base
and more information about mostly
reproductive psychiatry um we know that
certain difficulties and um
psychological difficulties that you have
can erupt when you're pregnant or
postpartum so we wanted to have a number
of resources available to women in the
new york city area i was a membership
chair there for a number of years and
then i was the president of that
organization
i think 2009 to
2017. i don't have my cv but i think
that's about right
why is participation in professional
organizations important in your field
well it's important to me
because i do believe very much in
service i do believe very much in giving
back i do believe that it's important as
a psychologist who believes strongly in
in trauma psychology and helping people
that i can be part of a voice at the
table part of that
push to get policy and understanding
especially with the insurance companies
um to make sure that people are getting
you know the appropriate care that they
deserve so it's something that
just has always been part of my life and
varying degrees and as a psychologist i
feel like it's a you know a very
rewarding uh part of my job
do you attend professional conferences
yes i do
typically multiple times a year of
course covered through a little bit of a
wrench in that um since some things are
virtual but yes i routinely attend
conferences
and why do you think that's important
it's important to stay abreast of
developments in the field it's important
to
meet with your colleagues across the
country and see what they're doing and
what they're hearing and what's working
and what's not working um so when you're
when you're at a conference and
somebody's presenting newer novel
research then you can take that
information and that bring that back to
your clients and bring that back to my
forensic work so it actually absolutely
enhances the work that i do
have you ever been qualified to testify
in the field of psychology as an expert
witness yes i have how many times i was
first qualified in 1998 so since then um
about 50 times
and how often in that 50 times has the
specialty been in interpersonal violence
and traumatic stress
probably more than half okay
have you ever worked for or testified
for the prosecution in criminal matters
like the district attorney's office u.s
attorney's office yes i have frequently
okay
do you testify for both sides in
lawsuits plaintiffs and defendants yes i
do
have you ever worked on other cases that
didn't go to trial
many okay have you ever found an
individual that you evaluated did not
suffer from the effects of interpersonal
violence or ptsd
frequently okay
have you ever
not been qualified in court where you
have been proffered to qualify as an
expert in the court
now okay
your honor i would at this time move to
qualify dr hughes as an expert in
forensic psychology with the
specialization in interpersonal violence
and traumatic stress all right any
objection
no objection to qualifying her as an
expert in forensic psychology all right
my ex
more specifically forensic psychology
with a specialization in interpersonal
violence and traumatic stress any
objection
no all right so moved
thank you your honor
dr hughes
please tell the jury what domestic
violence intimate partner violence means
sure so i'm probably going to be
interchanging the language domestic
violence and interpersonal violence and
for purposes here these are the same
thing
so intimate partner violence is a
pattern of manipulation fear and
coercive control that happens within an
intimate relationship it constitutes
using a variety of abusive behaviors and
that can be physical violence sexual
violence psychological aggression
emotional abuse stalking or surveillance
behaviors and economic abuse
the abusive behaviors occur over time
not all at once
and they're also interspersed with very
normal times times without violence
times with love and happiness and it's
this inter positioning of the violence
with the love and the abu with the love
and the care that makes it very
difficult for a victim to extricate
herself from that situation and from
that
relationship and what would you say is
the overarching dynamic of these
relationships so the overarching dynamic
is the um abuse of power and control of
one person wanting to have dominance in
that relationship say over most things
that the couple or that the victim does
or does not do
please tell the jury what coercive
control means
so coercive control is a tactic of
victimization
the goal of it is to
establish dominance what coercive
control does is that it imposes negative
consequences for non-compliance with
your partner's expectations or demands
and what that does is it erodes away at
the victim's autonomy and her
independence
what is physical violence
so physical violence is when one person
uses their body against the body of
another with the intent to cause injury
or harm
that can be
push shove slap kick
punch beat up meaning multiple types of
physicality in one instance
throw slam into a wall
push into something hard that you could
hurt yourself clearly use of a weapon
would be a physically violent act as
well
the size and strength matter between the
parties
yes very much so um this is very well
documented in the literature about
violence and abuse and relationships and
and that's just um that's just physics
that's just proportional force that if a
185 pound man is going to push a 120
pound woman that's going to feel quite
different than 120 pound woman pushing
185 pound man and it's just about
proportional force and the size and
strength differential
and that is why specifically if you look
at
wrestling or boxing they match weight
classes and they do that for a reason
because they know that it's not fair if
somebody is bigger and stronger than the
other so it's certainly not the only
factor but it is a factor that one has
to consider if a relationship is violent
what is psychological aggression
so psychological aggression is threats
and the imposition of threats with the
intent to control someone's behavior so
it's doing
doing a threat so that you will modify
your behavior and do what your partner
wants
some psychological aggression techniques
are intimidation um slamming your hand
on uh on a table punching a wall
throwing something
mumbling under your mouth cursing
screaming sort of these these high
emotional balance type of activities
that can cause a victim to feel afraid
and feel intimidated
and then if there has been um an act of
physical violence where that contingency
has already been established that
this person your partner has said okay i
will not only have the ability to use
violence against you i also have the
willingness to do it the intimidating
tactics take on a greater flavor they
take on greater salience they need more
because you know what could be coming
down the pike
what is emotional abuse
so emotional abuse functions to
denigrate a person's sense of self-worth
and their their self
perception it's about name-calling being
very mean-spirited putting yourself down
using gender-based uh language that's
offensive racial slurs all types of
behaviors to really make a person feel
less than they actually should
and what is sexual abuse
so sexual abuse in an intimate
relationship
functions to establish dominance and dis
established power
what it is simply
in the psychological and psychiatric
communities is forcing someone to do
something sexual against your will when
you did not want to um it can be forced
sex either forced vaginal oral anal sex
and be forced to engage in
any other type of sexual act that you
may not want to do
and when i say force it doesn't mean it
has to have physical force there's a lot
of
psychologically coercive tactics that
are used that many times when violence
has already been established in the
relationship the victim often feels that
she can't say no for fear of reprisal
for fear of retaliation for saying no to
those acts
so sexual abuse you know does happen in
intimate partner relationships a lot of
people don't want to talk about it and
they don't want to ask about it because
it makes people very uncomfortable
is digital penetration of the vagina
sexual abuse
it's leading
what if any role does digital
penetration of the vagina play in sexual
abuse
if it is non-consensual
then it is abusive
what if any penetration of inanimate
objects into the vagina plays a role in
sexual abuse again the operative word is
consensual if you are not consenting to
those acts then it is sexually abusive
is there a distinction between sexual
violence and sexual abuse
not really sexual violence is a term of
art it is the overarching umbrella that
we in the psychological and psychiatric
communities talk about so if we are
looking at our diagnostic and
statistical manual and say what are the
traumas that could cause ptsd it's
listed as sexual violence so it's an
umbrella term that allows us to
understand it could be childhood sexual
abuse it could be a rape a sexual
assault it can be sexual abuse in an
intimate relationship so it's really
just an overarching term um that we use
in the field
what are the i'm sorry so it doesn't
mean i think people often mistake it to
mean that when you are being sexually
abused that someone's punching you or
someone's hitting you or someone's doing
something like that because you hear the
violence it does not mean that that
could happen but that term does not
require that nor does it mean that
what are stacking or surveillance
behaviors
so stalking and surveillance behaviors
are a common tactic of of typically men
um who use violent behaviors in an
intimate relationship what they do is
they allow the
woman to know that wherever she is
wherever she goes he's gonna know um i'm
going to maybe look at your phone see
who you're talking to track you on find
my iphone look at your instagram look at
your emails you know really having a way
of knowing all of the personal
information about you and what that does
it again erodes the victim's autonomy
and it roads her sense of privacy she
doesn't feel that wherever she can go
that somewhere he's not going to be
part of her life in an in
a very objectionable way sometimes
there's the pop-ins they'll show up at
places that they're not supposed to be
and that we don't want them to be just
as a way of checking sometimes they'll
have friends or family check up on their
partners to make sure where they are
what time did you get home but you
didn't turn off your phone at this time
but you came in the door this time like
all of the sort of constant questioning
and interrogation about an individual's
whereabouts
what about economic abuse what is that
so economic abuse is a way to again
continue to maintain control over your
intimate partner sometimes it's
withholding information about the
finances of not letting you have access
to the finances if you can't have access
to a credit card or a checking account
or you know apple pay on your phone then
you're
rendered usually much more economically
dependent on your partner and that
limits tangible options for you um for
individuals where um that sort of
tangible options isn't there we see the
economic abuse or the economic
restriction when one partner refuses to
share any information about the funds so
it's not like i can't go shopping
because i won't have money but i don't
have any decision making in our family
money i don't have any idea of what
we're doing in our family
vis-a-vis our finances so it's a way of
definitely keeping that very separate
and not in a consensual some couples
make that choice one person does all the
money that's fine but when it doesn't
come from a place of of consensual
choice making it can be um abusive
so
you you just described a number of these
abusive behaviors
are all of them present in every uh
domestic violence relationship right no
they're not all present in everyone and
that's why it's very important to do a
thorough assessment of a relationship
that may be mired in violence to see
which ones are present and which ones
have a great impact in the relationship
which ones are sort of making the
structure of this relationship
after a sexual assault in an intimate
relationship how might a victim in those
circumstances interact with her partner
so so this is one of the myths that
people say well if she was sexually
assaulted by her partner she would have
just left
and nothing could be further from the
truth that's not what happens
especially when it's your your husband
or your boyfriend or your partner um so
what women do is they they bury it they
compartmentalize it they they put it
away they avoid it because then they
continue to to reach out for the kind
and the loving man that they got into
this relationship with you know the
problem is that it does fester belief
and causes more sort of psychological
distress
in the victim
what if any role can shame or
humiliation play in this coercive
dynamic
so so that's one of the emotions that um
the victim is usually trying to to
suppress and compartmentalize and avoid
and put away um one of the most
you know
frequently felt feelings after something
so incredibly humiliating and violating
is shame um and shame is a very sort of
difficult emotion for people to have to
live with and to have to experience and
then a lot of times what we see in in
these relationships especially ones
where
sexual assault is perpetrated there's
typically the emotional abuse as well so
now if you're be you're called names
like a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and easy and fat
and you're feeling the shame from the
sexual assault that just happened it
sort of acts as a compounding effect and
it sort of kind of slowly deteriorates
the psychological functioning of the
victim and where they're just really
trying to get back to the good guy get
the good guy to come back but they're
suffering these symptoms underneath
what about intimidation what role does
intimidation play in the coercive
control dynamic
intimidation is one of the the huge
factors that we see in coercive control
again the goal is to get your partner to
do what you want them to do and if
you've established that you can use
violence and other sexual violence and
physical violence slamming your hands on
a table throwing a glass breaking a door
you know throwing anything causing a fit
yelling and screaming you know that can
rise the fear level in a victim that she
may modify her behavior quicker and he
might not need to use physical violence
because he's already established that
that fear is there
what if any role could writing obscene
messages
play in being considered intimidating
behavior
objection leading
i said what if any your honor overruled
i mean certainly writing obscene
messages to your partner could
absolutely be an intimidating behavior
what if any role does emotional abuse or
degradation play in the dynamics
so emotional abuse and degradation as i
stated before functions to
decrease your sense of self-worth it
decreases your sense of agency it makes
you feel bad about yourself and when you
feel bad about yourself you're less
likely to actualize and see options for
leaving you're so sort of mired in in
this dynamic of abuse that you come
sometimes to believe the bad things that
the person is telling you about so you
know maybe i am not talented and fat and
lazy and stupid and it interferes with
that ability to problem solve and figure
out you know can i get out of this
relationship and sometimes you feel you
don't even deserve to get out of the
relationship when the abuse is so
chronic and so repetitive
what role does surveillance as a means
of control play in that dynamic
so surveillance objection
i don't think that's leading your
overall goal
so surveillance functions to let the
victim know wherever you are there i am
so it makes her feel
not secure in her movement feeling that
she has to restrict her movement her
movement is not hers alone
it usually increases hyper vigilance it
increases fear it increases
the need
to for yourself to mark where you've
been and what you've done so that you
can go back and prove it to your partner
because you know that there is going to
be an interrogation later when this this
pattern has been established show
receipts you know show me your iphone
where were you what's your google
location at you know those are some
types of surveillance behaviors that
puts the victim very much on edge and
increases that level of anxiety and
trepidation
what role does possessive jealousy play
in these relationships so possessive
jealousy is a very um
difficult dynamic in intimate partner
violence it's very common in situations
of coercive control it's rooted in in
possession that the
gentleman feels that he can possess her
and that he can have her whenever he
wants is very possessive dynamic um but
the accusations the problem is when you
make the accusations the woman's forced
to refute the accusations so they're
continuing in this dynamic where she's
trying to prove i i didn't do what you
said this didn't happen and then
unfortunately sometimes it escalates
because the the man is not taking the no
for an answer because this is a a
perseverative obsessive pattern that's
very difficult to
penetrate
that often these type of conversations
lend themselves to physical and sexual
violence
does this dynamic happen overnight
no it doesn't happen overnight it
happens over time we don't
you know woman doesn't get into a
relationship with a man who's beating
her up and sexually assaulting her and
calling her names and doing all that
you know she gets into the relationships
for all the right reasons just like we
all get into relationships for love for
companionship for kindness for a future
um but then slowly you know all of these
behaviors start to take form and i say
it's sort of like sucking the oxygen out
of the room and then before you know it
you're suffocating
so
and and that brings me to my next
question what uh what role do physical
abuse and coercive tactics play
interspersed with normalcy and positive
moments
objection compound
i'll sustain the objection okay
i'll figure this out some way um
what role does love and normalcy play
in these dynamics you've been describing
objection compound
thank you
so love and normalcy are almost always
in these relationships that you know
when you are
in a lull and the violence is not
happening you're back to sort of the the
loving man that you wanted the person
who you wanted to be with
and when you pair
sort of this
this violent dynamic physical violence
sexual violence with love and attachment
it creates a trauma bond it creates a
psychological bond and emotional
dependency is created so it makes it
very difficult for
the victim of the abuse to extricate
herself from that relationship and for
her to even believe frankly i mean that
takes a lot of time to even believe that
she can
and that she should
and
what if any role does that dynamic
you've described have in the victim
thinking they can fix the problem
so what do we know from the research
the research with working with battered
men who come into treatment is that the
only person who can change the abuse is
the abuser so no matter what the tactics
that the woman uses and she's trying to
do all these different things to fix him
to have him not be violent to have him
not be sexually violent have him not be
obsessively jealous
and all those things
don't change his behavior
because it's up to him to change his
behavior and this was
played out a million times in in the
batterers intervention groups that i led
and that the men would tell us it
doesn't matter what she does i don't
care um so the problem is is that the
woman continues to think that she can
fix it
and yet she can't
but she's the one who's then rendered
sort of helpless and hopeless because
everything that she's trying to do is
failing
what is the cycle of violence
so the cycle of violence is one way to
describe this domestic violence pattern
um typically what we see in the cycle
can be different in a variety of
relationships but typically what we see
is in the first phase of sort of
multiple three to four phases
in the first phase there's a tension
building phase you're sort of starting
to feel that that apprehension he may be
throwing his papers on the table a
little more he may be slamming the
fridge door a little more he may be
mumbling under his mouth a little more
he may grab a glass a little more
forcefully than he normally is
and then there's the incident phase then
there's the blow-up where the violence
the abuse the screaming the sexual
violence or the physical violence all
that occurs
then we come to the contrition phase
i'm sorry
i didn't mean it
it wasn't me
i'm not going to do it again the
promises for change
and then we sort of slide into the calm
phase where you know this isn't going to
happen again i'm back to stable ground i
want to live in this place this sort of
honeymoon place you know the problem in
the calm phase is we often see
the rationalizations and the
justifications for the behavior it's not
like typically the man is taking full
responsibility for what he did but it's
calm because there's no
you know violence and no sort of tension
at that moment um
and then it recurs
and then it recurs um so you're stuck in
this vicious cycle of trying to figure
out how can i be with this man who hurts
me
and yet i love him so much
and
what if anything does the term love bomb
mean
so so the love bombing is um it's more
of the colloquial term for for the
younger folks here but you know where
you shower someone with with affection
and love you know in this contrition and
calm phase where you know your
everything about you is special you're
the best thing in the world i'm never
gonna do anything to hurt you again i
would never let anyone hurt you and it
could be selling sending flowers and
buying gifts or going on trips or your
favorite restaurant
um and that is you know a way of where
the man is trying to make those amends
um and then it gets the woman hooked so
they get hooked on the kindness they get
hooked on the love they don't get hooked
on the abuse i've never met one woman in
the hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
that i've evaluated who was not
concerned about the violence they're all
concerned about the violence
but they go for the love
so
in in your experience with with these
dynamics that you've described
does the victim ever yell at her partner
absolutely why
we know from the research that women use
verbal and physical acts of aggression
in these relationships that's not
uncommon this has been researched for
five decades
and a woman may yell at her partner
because she's angry and it anger is a
very normal emotion to having been
abused she can also be afraid
but they don't have to be mutually
exclusive we can absolutely as human
beings feel
two or three or four different motions
at once
you know people do often say to me oh
she would never yell at him if she knew
he was going to hit her
and that's not true that's just patently
not true that doesn't that's not
supported in the research and that's not
supported in my clinical practice you
know the problem is is there's a classic
double bind and the violence has been so
normalized in the relationship now she
gets hit if she does yell she gets hit
if she doesn't yell so for women who
feel at certain moments that they need
to preserve some sense of their autonomy
and their independence and stand up for
themselves they will yell and they will
fight back even though the risk
of violence is there
so it doesn't mean that she's not afraid
and that she's not concerned about the
violence and it doesn't mean she doesn't
also use
placating and compliance strategies most
of the time as well
does
does
in the cases that you have in your
experience
does the abuse typically take place in
front of others
no i mean this is classically what we
talk about behind closed doors most of
the intimate partner violence the
domestic violence happens you know in
the privacy of your own home so
sometimes we see the remnants of it the
after effects or victims talk to their
friends or family about it but very
rarely are you seeing it happen the
actual blow-up phase happen
in the middle of witnesses and other
people
what does the term bystander effect mean
so bystander effect means what happens
when people are
aware that domestic violence is
happening what happens when they're
aware even if they're not seeing it
that it could be happening and what
happens is we know that it's very
difficult for people to to stand up and
say something it's very difficult
especially in situations where
there's a larger community of folks and
the person who perhaps is perpetrating
the abuse is the leader of that
community
it becomes very difficult to go up
against that to go up against the sort
of the head honcho of the community
people are very fearful of losing their
jobs
i've seen this time and time again in in
the cases that i've worked on
either the boy scout cases or the clergy
abuse cases you know all of those type
of cases where the usa gymnastics where
when we go back and we look we see
people new but the secretary doesn't
want to lose her job she has kids to
feed the guy who you know checks you in
he doesn't want to lose his job because
he has a mortgage to pay
so people are quiet and they don't say
anything um you know and then other
people are are very um
it's a very worrisome dynamic they don't
want to put their foot out there if
they're wrong and maybe i didn't see it
right or i don't really know what
happened i certainly am not going to
jeopardize my job
if i don't really know what happened
behind closed doors even if i see
a trash room or a bruise um
and then people still believe it's a
family matter you know it's between
amber and johnny let them figure it out
you know i'm not going to get in the
middle
so those are dynamics that happen
what's the objection
motion to strike
what's the objection
we identified two names in the answer
uh overrule
thank you
question did you finish your answer yes
i believe so okay
what about mutual abuse what is that
what role does that play
so mutual abuse isn't really a term of
art that we use what we look at is
situational couple violence
and intimate partner violence and when
we look at situational couple bonds that
really does characterize the majority of
types of violence and abuse that happens
in relationships that's when a couple
gets out of hand they may push shove
slap yell say some things that they
don't want and it's not that those
behaviors are okay but those are sort of
what the our larger sale community-based
studies say happens in these
relationships that's distinguished from
intimate partner violence what i'm
talking to you about that has this
constellation of symptoms and is rooted
in
the abuse of power and control
is there research that addresses this
mutual abuse
yeah there's research that addresses
what does um
gender symmetry look like male and
female are they the same um and there's
certainly as i said research that on the
um the lower end types of violent
behaviors push shove slap
you know we may see similar rates
between men and women in psychological
aggression yelling name-calling putting
down
in some of our big community scale
studies we may see similar rates of
perpetration in those behaviors
but then there are you know other
situations where we don't have gender
symmetry and what the research talks
about very clearly is you have to
examine context you have to examine the
differential of power and control and
coercive control in the relationship to
make a full determination
do women use violence in relationships
absolutely and we've known this for five
decades in our research we've been
studying this since the 70s and when we
look at what happens you know women do
report their use of violence
the majority of violence that we do see
is what we call reactive violence or
self-defense violence or sometimes
violence that's perpetrated
independently of of an assault of
something that's going on but mostly
that when the partner begins to come
violent then she may become violent and
fight back
and that's not an uncommon dynamic that
if somebody is being pushed or shoved or
hit that a person would fight back that
has been established
in the research
and what if any effect does that have on
changing the power dynamics or the
structure well you have to find out does
it does her use of violence change the
overarching power structure of coercive
control
and violence and abuse in this
relationship and you have to examine
those variables to see does it or does
it not
can men be victims of intimate partner
violence
absolutely
certainly we know that we have to be
careful of gendered stereotypes we can't
go in and think oh only the woman is the
victim or and only the man is the
perpetrator that just does not comport
with the research we know that
the research also shows that we can have
domestic violence and same-sex
relationships my very first case was a
same-sex domestic violence homicide in
brooklyn um so i've been that was in
1998 so i've been examining and treating
individuals in a variety type of violent
context
so we have to be careful that that bias
doesn't get in our way when we're
evaluating a particular situation in a
particular case um that said we do know
that there still are differences you
know in a heterosexual couple in a male
female dyad the research still is clear
that there are differences men still
perpetrate more severe acts of violence
women are still more likely to be
injured they are much more likely to
suffer
sexual violence at the hands of their
partner they're more likely to be
intimidated afraid and they're much more
likely to be killed so we know that
those differences exist but we do
examine you know in those individual
circumstances knowing that either one
could be a perpetrator or a victim
so how are you able to determine whether
a relationship is a situational violence
or intimate partner violence
so i thoroughly examine all of those
other variables i look for the coercive
control who holds the power in the
situation who's able to say no who makes
the decisions what are the consequences
if you don't follow the decisions of
your partner is there sexual violence is
there intimidation and fear
are there statistical factors that are
associated with severe and lethal
domestic violence so there's a lot of
data that we have in the field that we
can use to assess a particular
relationship and really find out what's
going on
does alcohol and substance use cause
people to be violent
oh it certainly doesn't cause people to
be violent um we have plenty of people
who can be you know struggling with
substance abuse and addiction and
they're not violent but when you have a
substance abuse an addiction
and you perpetrate domestic violence it
does create a a much more disastrous
effect it is a co-occurring variable and
we know that also from the research that
the majority of the women will report
that when their partner is drinking the
physical violence goes up
so a lot of the times when he's
physically violent
is when he's been consuming drugs or
alcohol
when he's not consuming drugs and
alcohol and he's not violent those other
behaviors continue to persist the
coercive control the surveillance the
obsessive jealousy the possessiveness
the psychological abuse those usually
persist but the alcohol can just throw
lighter fluid on a flame
in a situation of domestic violence
is there research that looks at how
women cope with the violence and abuse
in their relationships yes there is
please tell me about it what does it say
so there's been a lot of research to
talk about what do women do that's the
question that everyone wants to know why
doesn't you just leave
and in asking that question why doesn't
she just leave we actually are able to
say well let me tell you what she does
do and and what the research shows is
women do a lot of things in that
relationship so sort of three main
categories one of the formal
responses the formal things that she
does
call the police participate in
prosecution of your partner go see a
therapist go to a shelter go to a
hospital these are sort of the very
formal strategies
that women can use then they're the
informal strategies and that's talking
with your best friend talking with your
mom talking with your friends trying to
get that emotional support from your
social network but the most common one
is these personal strategies and the
personal strategies are really talking
with your partner they're trying to fix
the relationship
from within the confines of the
relationship you know trying to get him
to go to counseling try to get him to go
to church try to get him to understand
his ways try to get him to get into aaa
or sober counseling or harm reduction
model to help with his addiction
compliance with his demands anticipating
his demands all these coping strategies
that are sort of you know embedded
within that intimate relationship
let's talk about the calling the police
is that a common response
it's not a common response
many women do not want to call the
police on their partners
you know using criminal justice
interventions in crimes of
women and children are the least likely
to be called into law enforcement
and most of the time when the police are
called it's because a particular
incident has got out of hand and she
feels unsafe and the only way that she
feels i can get this incident to end and
stop
is by calling law enforcement
and if police are called does the woman
typically participate in the prosecution
i mean this has been a a problem and a
difficulty for prosecutors across the
country um since i've been doing this
work i'm actually frequently called by
the prosecutor
to testify
about a fact pattern because the victim
won't come in and testify um so dropping
restraining orders not participating in
the prosecution is a very common dynamic
in in situations of intimate partner
violence domestic violence um and and
what we know and what we know from our
law enforcement data and colleagues is
that when you get when when you get that
9-1-1 call they're very specifically
trained to say
that's likely not the first episode the
chances are there have been more severe
episodes before you get this call so you
can't go on the scene and think that
this is the first episode of violence
and that's why a thorough assessment
is supposed to be done when police
officers arrive on the scene
so usually that episode that calls the
police is just meant to stop that
incident in that moment to get a sense
of safety
but most women don't want to participate
and go forward with restraining orders
why do women in violent relationships
stay in the relationship when the man's
hurting them
i mean they stay for all the reasons we
talked about in the cycle of violence
they stay for for the loving man they
say for the man who's kind they say for
the man they decided to marry and had
hope and promises for their future
so there's a lot of sort of love and
attachment is why they're connected to
their partner
some people stay because they have
economic reasons and they don't have
tangible resources to leave some people
have children in common and they don't
want to deprive their children of a
father
so some people fear retaliation if i
leave i'm going to get seriously hurt
and
frankly the statistics bear it out the
most dangerous time for a woman is when
she's leaving that relationship her
likelihood of being killed grows
substantially at that moment so leaving
sometimes isn't the best strategy
staying keeps her safe
so there's usually a whole mo a
multitude of factors of why a woman
decides to stay in the relationship and
again as i said previously it doesn't
mean she's unconcerned about the
violence just she hasn't figured out a
way
out yet
what if any role does emotional
attachment and love play in that
that's you know probably the biggest one
is that you you have this we talked
about that trauma bond that has
developed that psychological attachment
to your partner um you don't want to
leave him you you've connected with him
on so many other levels that giving that
up just feels like a threat to your
integrity you're just sort of and a
threat to his um because you're just so
intertwined and attached what if any
role does hope and optimism play
hope and optimism are really what keeps
victims alive in these situations
that's what gets them going from one
episode to the next to get up the next
day and maybe he's not going to drink
today maybe it's going to be on his good
side maybe he's going to come home and
not disappear for three days continuing
to hope that some type of change is
coming down the pike now you mentioned
lethality a little earlier can you
please explain to us what that means
so lethality is um
means death means fatality
and we have very well validated
instruments and data that looks at what
factors happen in a relationship
where a woman ends up dead
and we do that through looking
retrospectively saying you know here's
you know this person ended up um
dead killed by her partner in a homicide
and let's see what factors were there so
that we can work at preventing it um
it's very methodologically sound over
different case
control designs over multiple cities
viewed by the fbi and law enforcement
so these are a number of factors that
tell us that somebody is in a very
dangerous situation
so some of the factors are an increase
of frequency and severity of the
violence threats to kill
choking behavior sexual assault
obsessive and possessive jealousy
controlling behavior the perpetrator's
use and abuse of substances alcohol and
substances the perpetrators
threatening of suicide himself right
those are some of the top factors
and there are more that are are very
very dangerous when we hear that and we
hear a woman is in a situation where
those are present
then we are moving out of situational
couple violence
what if any role does destroying
property and destroying property
destruction of property personal
property is also one of the risk factors
uh for danger and and fatality and what
if any role does leaving threatening
messages play
that's also a risk factor for for
lethality
what are the psychological and traumatic
effects that such interpersonal violence
has on victims objection compound
psychological and traumatic effects are
kind of interchangeable sustained
objection
what are the psychological effects that
such interpersonal violence has on
victims so these have also been well
researched and they are wide and varied
we see depression and depressive
disorders sometimes with suicidality we
see anxiety and anxiety disorders a lot
of stress we see post-traumatic stress
disorder we see substance abuse and
substance abuse disorders we see trust
difficulties and difficulties in
interpersonal relationships as a result
we see a lot of shame and humiliation we
see anger and rage
a whole sleep disruption a whole host of
difficult psychological consequences
having sustained a relationship of
intimate partner violence
what if any role does low self-esteem
play well low self-esteem is a very
common after effect and and that you
know when you're embedded in the
relationship it also makes it just very
difficult for you to climb your way out
what is emotional dysregulation
emotional dysregulation so it's a dys
dysregulation um is when you sort of
don't feel that you have control of your
emotions you feel like you're
fluctuating you know from one to the
axis one to the next it's not the same
as a bipolar disorder it you know can
happen in short moments that you know
it's really because your central nervous
system is so out of haywire from um
being exposed to so many traumatic
events that you may feel things deeply
and with a short trigger and in a very
quick time
in your experience is there a particular
way victims of intimate partner violence
remember the violence they endured
well memory for uh traumatic events is
something that has been well researched
sometimes people have um what we call
dissociative amnesia where because of
the physical or psychic pain of what
they're going through
a portion of the memory either gets
blocked or can't get retrieved whether
it's stored or retrieval we're not
really sure
but most of the times the memory is
really about when you have multiple
repeated events of the same type of
thing
so if you are abused multiple times and
the abuse is very similar it's very
common for the victim to lose discrete
details of a particular incident they
may not retain the memory for the
complete incident and that might not be
to dissociative amnesia that just might
mean to forgetting because you have so
many chronic events that have happened
to you
are there common myths or misperceptions
about domestic violence
there are i hope i've dispelled some of
them here already but i mean the myths
you know certainly are that women are
meek or passive are you know just
sitting there and letting the abuse
happen that women don't fight back that
women don't yell back that they
some old ones that they like the
violence they're not concerned about the
violence that if it was really bad she
really would have left
if it was really bad she really would
have told the police all of those myths
and misconceptions
that just don't comport with the
research
are there also myths about trauma
survivors
what what house trauma survivors present
yes there are and what we say is um you
know how
lay people think someone who suffered a
traumatic event is supposed to act um so
in the immediate aftermath of a trauma
people think oh they should be
hysterical and ab reacting and emotional
all over the place
and that's typically not the first
reaction of a trauma survivor the first
reaction is you know
suppression
emotional numbing emotional constriction
how do i get through this you know women
who are beaten they get up the next
morning they get their kids dressed they
get them to school they go to work they
do a presentation in their office they
go on with life the most normal thing
that a person does who've experienced
trauma is to get up and try to be normal
they're striving for that all the time
so sometimes if you see somebody who is
more emotionally constricted looks maybe
stoic looks like they're not feeling it
doesn't mean that they're not having
internal reactions we say this in the
field of clinical psychology all the
time the inside doesn't match the
outside what you're seeing on the
outside may not match what's going on
for the person inside because they have
to be so controlled because the fear is
is that if i let out a little of this
emotion
i'm not going to be able to put the
floodgates back on it's just going to be
too overwhelming and that's true for
people who are involved in litigation
and also true for my private patients
who are even though they're coming to me
for help they try
very very cleverly to not want to feel
um the difficult emotions of the trauma
that they experienced
and
is it is it
also possible that they can look very
friendly and smile and laugh and things
like that yeah
and compound
sustain uh what if any uh
please describe some of the ways that
that a victim can hide that as you you
just testified too we call that the
appearance of normalcy the appearance of
competency right that and it doesn't
mean that they're not it doesn't mean
that they're not normal and that they're
not competent but it doesn't give you a
bird's eye into their inner experience
and that's what we do
in the we say in the rooms in the rooms
of therapy where we really help people
deal with that that they keep to
themselves but yes someone can be
smiling and happy it doesn't mean that
they're not suffering inside
is there a single profile that fits all
women in domestic violence situations no
is there a single profile of a man who
perpetrates intimate partner violence no
you are i'm at a point of moving to a
new top topic area i don't know what
your aunt wants to do because i know we
switched the launcher out i'm perfectly
happy to keep going but if this was a
good stopping point we could make that
for their break
all right let's go ahead and take our
afternoon break for 15 minutes okay just
do not discuss the case and do not do
any outside research okay
all right and dr hugh since you are
testifying please not discuss your
testimony including the attorneys at
this point okay yes all right we'll come
back at 3 15 then okay thank you
all right
all right
are you ready for the jury yeah okay
uh
uh
all right be seated all right
your next question
thank you your honor
doctor hughes did there come a time when
you conducted a forensic psychological
evaluation of amber heard
and
please tell the jury what a forensic
psychological evaluation is
could you turn it on at the bottom base
okay
a forensic psychological evaluation
is an evaluation that is conducted for
the courts to answer a particular legal
question
it contains multiple parts ms hurd is
not a client of mine she's never been in
therapy with me i'm not under my
clinical care it is an objective
evaluation to determine a particular
legal question
forensic evaluation follows a
methodology that what we say it's a
multi-method
multi-hypothesis driven
methodology which means i look at a
variety of different
documents and data
using multiple hypotheses it's not just
one hypothesis one theory of the case
you're going in looking to see you know
what possibly could be going on here and
then you use the data to arrive at that
opinion you look for consistency across
the data to arrive at that opinion
and the forensic psychological
evaluation has many parts it has the
clinical interview part a structured or
semi-structured clinical interview where
i'm asking miss heard lots of things
about her life both before
mr depp and after it involves a
psychological testing component of the
evaluation which allows me to do a good
broad scan of different symptomatologies
that people might have in their lives as
well as to have indicators of how she
approached the test is she defensive is
she malingering is she feigning is she
exaggerating it gives me indications
about how she approached the evaluation
i review a number of documents medical
records psychological records the text
the audio all the different things that
we've had in this case
and then i conduct collateral interviews
so dr hughes do you just to be clear do
you assume everything
the victim reports is true when you
conduct these examinations no of course
not i always approach a forensic
evaluation with a healthy dose of
skepticism um with any forensic
evaluation there there exists a
motivation that the individual may be
telling you something that is not
accurate it doesn't mean that that's
there but you have to control for that
um and know that you're looking for
again what does the data tell you the
external data about what the person is
also telling you
did the forensic evaluation follow a
standard methodology or was it specific
to ms heard no this is my standard
methodology that i would use with any
individual
who's in a forensic matter and i was
called to evaluate them
when did you meet with amber heard
okay so i met with miss heard
for a total of about 29 hours i met with
her for the first time in september 2019
i saw her for four visits
in live in my new york city office
i that's about 21 22 hours and then i
saw her twice over zoom one was in
january 2021 and
new approach okay
uh
dr korea in answering that question were
you consulting anything dr hughes dr i'm
so sorry
uh dr hughes were you consulting
anything dr cruz here i guess as well
um i'm concerned through my cheat sheet
of the dates that i saw misheard so that
i could accurately um report to the
court i also have my final designation
in front of me so that i could give the
most accurate information to what i put
in that report okay okay and do you want
to see that
okay
should we just take the break now and
have him look at it or just would you
like to look at an hour before crosstalk
it's just to post it
i happen to look at it
okay before crosstalk okay all right
that's fine thank you
okay um
please continue i think you were telling
us when you saw him is heard
sure um
so there were four dates uh in person in
new york city uh for a total of about 21
and half hours and then i saw her
in january 18 2021 over zoom for three
hours and then december 27th 2021
for four hours over zoom
and what did the evaluation consist of
so as i stated the evaluation consisted
of psychological testing
a semi-structured clinical interview
with ms heard a review of a whole host
of documents relative to this case and
medical records and psychological
records and then three collateral
interviews two with her treating
therapists dr bonnie jacobs dr connell
cohen and also with her mom
and in the semi-structured clinical
interview what were you assessing
well when someone comes in for the
evaluation you sometimes don't know what
you're going to see or what you're going
to get so you absolutely have to do a
full clinical interview and have a sense
of their life their life patterns things
that have affected them in their lives
you know where they have worked where
they have lived just get a full sense of
their um their sort of being before the
incident for which they're talking about
then i do a full intimate partner
violence assessment looking at all those
characteristics that i talked to you
about earlier to get a sense of the full
structure of and the dynamic of this
relationship
i also did uh looking at what were the
effects what were the psychological
consequences of being in that
relationship and i also looked at the
psychological consequences of some of
the statements
that were made by mr depp through his
attorney that are part of this uh the
counter claim in this lawsuit
at the end of that process considering
all the data
did you arrive at any expert opinions
yes i did
all right i'm going i'd like to start
with your main expert opinions and then
go through those can you please tell the
jury what your main opinions were
um so like i said there are opinions
embedded within them but the main
opinion is that ms heard's report of
intimate partner violence
and the records that i reviewed is
consistent with what we know in the
field about intimate partner violence
characterized by physical violence
psychological aggression
sexual violence coercive control
and surveillance behaviors
and what was the other
main opinion that you had
the second main opinion was that
that misheard demonstrated very clear
psychological
and traumatic effects or the
exacerbation of trauma from those
statements that mr deb made through his
attorney there were three statements
that we evaluated to see how they
affected her emotionally and
psychologically and it was in my
determination that they did
and did you arrive at any diagnostic
conclusions yes i did and what were
those
i diagnosed uh misheard with
post-traumatic stress disorder
uh and what if any etiology
was associated with the post-traumatic
stress disorder so the etiology is the
cause
in order to have a to meet criteria for
post-traumatic stress disorder you have
to have an actual cause it's one of the
few diagnoses diagnostic entities that
we have to have a cause for and the
cause was the intimate partner violence
by mr depp that was the what was pushing
the symptoms that was what related to
the intrusive phenomena that was related
to her avoidance that was elated to her
differences in her mood that was related
to her avoidance efforts
so it was the the cause was the intimate
partner violence by mr deb
okay
now let's first go back to the forensic
evaluation you mentioned you reviewed
documents what documents did you review
so i'm going to refer to my list of
documents so that i can be clear for you
all
it is a four page
all right if you want to approach
dr curry um
if if you i mean dr hughes i don't know
why
my apologies my apologies dr hughes
i think it's the confusion of having her
in the courtroom um dr hughes uh
if um if you need to consult your notes
to answer something let us know that you
need to consult your notes um otherwise
try to answer to the best of your
ability and then if if you need to do
that just let us know you're consulting
your notes okay
the concern is uh that you not read from
them that you consult them as you need
to okay
correct i just don't want this to be a
memory test of having conducted many
documents 80 pages of notes 12
psychological testings to you can
reference your notes just don't read
from them okay yeah no problem okay okay
great
so please tell us what documents you
reviewed please tell the jury
okay so i reviewed a number of documents
a plethora of documents um most and i
obviously won't read them all um but i
reviewed certainly all of um miss
heard's testimony that she gave um in
her deposition testimony her deposition
testimony in this case her deposition or
her trial testimony in the uk case
i did the same thing from mr depp i
reviewed his deposition testimony as
well as his child testimony
in the uk as well i reviewed
a number of the depositions that were
put forth in this case i reviewed the
psychological treatment notes for dr
bonnie jacobs dr connell cohen dr laurel
anderson and dr amy banks although she
did not have treatment records so i
reviewed not only their records did
collateral interviews with some of them
and also read their deposition testimony
and also read other medical records in
this case nursing notes in this case
and the highlights and i also listened
to
the audios that were put forth in this
case and read the text messages and
emails
and
what if anything did you do with respect
to any videos and i also saw
the video in the kitchen yes okay
now
the collateral interviews that you
conducted why did you conduct those
well collateral interviews is a standard
part of a forensic evaluation it's an
opportunity to hear from another
treating clinician the person who's
actually treating the individual you're
evaluating and get a better sense from
that person of what they saw what they
knew how they experienced this person
sometimes our clinical notes don't give
the full breadth of um what really was
going on in that therapy because the
notes are meant to be sort of shortened
to the point of what was what happened
who was there and what was the plan um
so it was really helpful to talk to
these two clinicians who really were
with
miss heard throughout the duration of
her relationship with mr depp so they
gave us sort of a contemporaneous
look at what was going on for her
emotionally and then what was she
reporting what was she saying about the
relationship um to her therapist
and you mentioned the name dr bonnie
jacobs please tell the jury who dr
bonnie jacobs is so dr bonnie jacobs was
um miss herd's therapist and
may i refresh my recollection with my
notes your honor
she's she's allowed to for the days if
you'd like me to tell the dates
if she's asking me a question
you're right
yes may i yes you may consult your notes
yes
objection you are
can we be here
go ahead go ahead oh thank you
um
so she treated with dr bonnie jacobs who
was a psychologist from october 2011
um through august 2014 um she actually
was seeing miss dr jacobs somewhat
earlier before she got in the
relationship with mr depp
and then she transferred care to dr
connell cohen who was referred by dr
kipper who was
the treating physician for mr depp and
then
later for miss heard and she treated
with dr cohen from um after she left dr
bonnie jacobs in september 2014 to june
7 2016.
okay thank you
um and so you and i guess you got ahead
of me there so you also talked to dr
cohen correct that's correct okay and
you also spoke with
paige heard did you say that's correct
and who is paige heard page heard is
amber heard's mother
okay and when did you speak with paige
hurd
i i spoke with all of these individuals
at the end of 2019. again i can check my
notes and let you know the exact date if
you'd like
i think the end of 19 yeah they all were
in the end of 19 yes all right and you
are you aware that paige hurd has since
died she died two years ago yes i am
aware sadly okay
now let's talk about the psychological
testing
uh you stated that you conducted
psychological testing is that correct
that is correct
can you
overrule it
can you please tell
tell the jury how many psychological
assessments you administered to amber
heard i administered 12.
can you please tell them tell the jury
what which ones you administered
so i am going to refer to my designation
that has the list so that i don't forget
anything okay
so i administered objection here say
your honor she can refresh her
recollection
as long as she's not reading it right
you just can't read that you're not
supposed to read from it but you can
refresh your recollection as you're
speaking
so i can look and just look up and
that's refreshing my recollection
okay all right if we could approach for
a moment
c
dr hughes can you tell the jury the
tests that you administered please yes i
can
um i administered the personality
assessment inventory which is a
broadband uh
to scan for
psychopathology and psychological
symptoms that people have i administered
the trauma symptom inventory too which
is an instrument to scan for
common traumatic effects that people
have i administered the miller forensic
assessment of symptoms test which is a
measure of malingering i administered
the post-traumatic stress disorder
checklist
for the fifth edition for the dsm-5 i
administered the clinician administered
ptsd scale for dsm-5
i administered the back depression
inventory the back anxiety inventory the
mood disorders questionnaire
the danger i did three uh
intimate partner violence measures the
conflict tactic scale the abusive
behavior observation checklist and the
danger assessment scale and then i also
did the life events checklist which
scans and gets us to ask about a lot of
traumatic events that an individual may
have experienced and we administer that
typically before
either doing the pcl or doing the caps
thank you were there any tests you
administered to amber heard that were
designed to reveal malingering or
feigning yes they were okay can you
please tell the jury about those
so malingering um is the false
production of psychological
symptomatology for the purpose of some
external material gain
feigning is
the false projection of psychological
symptomatology but with no
identification of what that gain may be
so basically fainting is saying your
mental health is worse than it actually
is
so i administered uh three of the tests
had validity indices built in that could
allow us to
address that question the mfast the
miller assessment uh
forensic assessment of symptoms test is
a specific malingering instrument it
looks at malingering psychopathology is
this someone you know malingering
psychopathology um she scored a zero on
that scale um so on that's on that test
sorry not the scale that test i'm so on
that test there was no evidence of the
lingering
on the tsi there are two
uh validity indices and she scored
within the normal range on those scores
as well one was slightly elevated but
when in testing the limits because it
has rare symptoms and
over-endorsed symptoms
i determined that that also was a valid
measure and then finally the pai the
large-scale 344 question instrument has
very robust validity scales on it to
test for exaggeration or feigning or
malingering
and she did not score in any of those
scores and those scales at all those
were not elevated
so the combined results between those
three tests
suggest to me that miss hurt is not
malingering her psychological
symptomatology
now dr curry testified that one test
showed quote intentional exaggeration in
the 98th percentile meaning that she
engaged in extreme levels of
exaggeration end of quote do you agree
with that i do not why
because that test the the scale that she
is referring to is the it's called atr
it's the atypical response scale as i
said that combines rare symptoms and
over-endorsed symptoms it's very
frequently elevated and people who have
high levels of distress and then
importantly on this test specifically it
says do not use the percentile rank it
is in the manual it is in italicies
because the way that this test was
normed it was normed on people who have
trauma so it's what we call negatively
skewed that means it falls on the tail
end of the continuum it is not a normal
curve where we would normal think
normally think of how a percentile would
work so you would not use the percentile
rank on this test
you want to approach yes
dr hughes please continue
um so that is a very inaccurate way to
describe that scale and that test
and
the atr scale on this test is probably
the least robust of our validity scale
so you would never make a comment like
that based on one scale if you don't
have consistency across data
and when you look at the consistency
across the testing
with the pai the tsi and the mfas and
there's research to support that that
when they go together you have a higher
degree of likelihood that this is not
feigned ptsd that this is not feigned
symptomatology um and then actually if i
look at the validity scores on the mmpi
2 that dr curry administered those
scales are not elevated for exaggeration
or malingering either so if i add that
now i have really robust data that
misheard is not malingering or fading
her psychological symptomatology
thank you
did you administer any tests that are
specific to domestic violence
yes i did which ones
so that was the con conflict tactic
scale the abusive behavior observation
checklist and the danger assessment
scale
and what did they
show i'm would like to refer to the
testing
to refresh it refresh my recollection
just a glance yes you may be clear with
the jury
so what the um
overall gist of the testing was was that
um
and the benefit of these tests is that
they allow me to ask for what mr depp
did to miss herd and then also what miss
heard did to mr depp so it was asking
about both sets of behavior um and
objection your honor
we're back to reading
she wasn't even looking down she was
looking at the jury
i don't know
go go ahead
please please continue
so what these tests show was that there
was a high degree of
serious violence perpetrated
by mr depp toward misheard
there was violence more on the mild
level perpetrated by ms hurd toward mr
depp with one
severe indicator which was the punching
that she indicated to me
there were scales about negotiation
about how much this couple tries to
figure out their problems
they both scored again this is misheard
reporting that but they both scored in
the high range where they're both saying
that yes we're trying to figure this out
we're trying to work out this
relationship um there were scores on the
psychological aggression scale where
miss uh mr depp engaged in more severe
acts of psychological aggression
whereas miss her did engage in also some
mild and severe acts of psychological
aggression
the amount of injury that was reported
was significantly higher and more severe
by
misheard what she was subjected to and
then she was subjected to
sexual violence where
mr depp based on her report was
subjected to none
and then the other on the danger
assessment scale
that there were
a number of factors that were related to
um severity um in
in violent relationships and a risk
factor when we look as i said earlier
when um
behaviors come up on this scale they're
very worrisome um very scary and we have
to take them seriously so there were a
number of behaviors that came up on this
scale such as
mr depps threatens to kill her
the increase in severity of the abuse
the forced sexual activity the choking
behavior his obsessive jealousy
objection foundation
talking about the test results
overall go ahead please continue
the obsessive jealousy the control
aspect and
his um threatening of
suicide to kill himself so those were
risk factors
that placed her in the increased danger
range
and this is a range that you know says
that we certainly have to advise women
of their risk and consult with
um
law enforcement if they're involved or
judges if they're involved
because this means that a woman is at
risk for more serious or lethal domestic
violence
so did the results of the psychological
tests you administered to amber heard
support a diagnosis of ptsd objection
leading if any
psychological tests did you administer
that supported a diagnosis of ptsd for
amber herd
sure so um there were four tests that
supported that diagnosis
one was the pai which was that 344
question large uh scale personality
inventory
on that test her largest subscale her
highest subscale was the one that
measures traumatic stress
so that was clinically significant on
the tsi two of her scales were the
intrusive
experiences dimension and the defense of
avoidance mentioned two of the classic
scales of trauma and ptsd
on the pcl which is the post traumatic
stress disorder checklist five
that she scored in all four domains of
ptsd and that's an instrument says how
much how much are you bothered by these
symptoms um and in all four clusters
which would be the intrusive
experiencing when things about the abuse
of the trauma enter your mind when you
did not want to want them to sometimes
they're cute sometimes they're uncued
she answered in the avoidance category
which is a second category of ptsd that
i do things to try not to think about
this to try not to feel this to try not
to get upset sometimes i avoid certain
people because they become a trigger for
me she scored in the what we call the
negative alterations in cognition and
mood changes in her thoughts and
feelings as a result of the abuse and
trauma and also in the physiological
hyperactivity
the hyper arousal the hyper vigilance
the startle response so on the pcl she
endorsed symptoms in all four of those
categories saying you know some of these
symptoms are bothering me a lot
and then finally the clinician
administered
ptsd scale for the dsm-5 and what that
allows me to do unlike the pcl is really
look at symptom severity and and symptom
frequency how is this really playing out
for this individual and similarly she
scored in all four categories of um of
trauma and of having intrusive
experiences and nightmares and avoidance
efforts and physiological hyperactivity
and changes in her mood and her thoughts
and her total score was a 28 which falls
in the moderate range so that means that
she has experiencing a moderate degree
of post-traumatic stress disorder
symptomatology and those tests allow me
to make that definitive diagnosis that
she suffers from ptsd
thank you what if any consideration did
you give to amber heard's history of
childhood abuse in making your diagnosis
i mean that was a significant
consideration given that um we know that
childhood well first of all we know that
people can experience multiple traumas
across the lifespan um and we wanted to
make sure that the symptoms that she was
experiencing were related to what she
experienced with mr depp and not her
childhood
and certainly you know earlier on in the
evaluation and when i evaluate and spoke
with her that was true and that was also
true on the latest measure the clinician
administered ptsd scale for dsm-5 the
caps five
and that's because the content you have
to look at what is the content of the
symptoms so it's not that someone says
oh yeah something traumatic comes into
my mind now what is it what comes into
your mind what bothers you what are the
triggers
and those were all specific to
miss herd's relationship with mr deb
the reason the childhood is also
significant is that we know that if
somebody suffers childhood abuse as a
child they are much more likely to have
an adult re-victimization um and they're
much more likely than to be more
vulnerable to obtaining a ptsd to
getting ptsd if they've had that prior
vulnerability
so it's a very strong vulnerability
characteristic to obtaining ptsd when
you have a subsequent trauma
the other aspect about her childhood
abuse is that she was raised in a family
of violence she was physically
abused by her father
she saw her father abuse her mother her
father was very explosive
and had violent outburst and both her
parents also struggled with substance
abuse very significantly so she had
learned from a very early age how to
caretake how to live in a situation that
is mired in chaos how do i take care of
a parent who's passed out nodded out
from heroin and how do i get up and get
my sister to school she learned at a
very early age that she had to figure
out how to do this in this scenario and
i would say lastly what that
environment taught her was that
she learned that she could love someone
who hurts her
she knew that people who hurt her also
can love her and she learned how to have
this
tolerance for cognitive inconsistency
this tolerance for two
should be diametrically opposed emotions
but she grew up knowing or believing
perhaps that this could happen
and she also believed that she could fix
him just like she tried to fix her
father and just like she tried to fix
her mother she truly truly believed that
she could fix mr depp and rid him of his
substance abuse problems
but that did not work
did you review dr curry's caps five that
she administered to amber heard yes i
did
um and
what if any agreement did you have with
dr curry's interpretation of the caps
five i didn't agree with her
interpretation having
been a trauma psychologist for over 25
years and administered hundreds of these
i found that there were flaws in how she
chose to administer it and then some of
the coding
misheard on that caps 5
to dr curry certainly reported
trauma-based symptomatology related to
the abuse by mr depp but somehow that
was not coded as such
and
did you
uh review dr curry's mmpi two that she
administered on amber heard um yes i did
and do you agree with her
interpretations on that test no i do not
why not
because this profile is a normal profile
it is there are no
clinical scores elevated above 65 which
is one and a half standard deviations of
the mean which is what we use to
determine clinical significance
and if none of those scales are elevated
it becomes very difficult for us to make
assumptions about a person's psychology
and their functioning now remember the
psychological testing generates
hypothesis about a person that we then
using our clinical judgment have to make
a decision about we have to make an
assessment about it
and if none of those scales are elevated
it just doesn't give us rich information
to make those determinations
the one scale which is accurate that was
elevated was one that measures defensive
responding sort of a protective
responding an unwillingness to
admit minor faults that was elevated and
that was true
but the result of that is you have a
defensive profile you have somebody
who's not giving you a lot of
information so the scales are all low so
there's no way you can take that mmpi
and then say it meets uh it's consistent
with borderline personality disorder you
just don't have the symptom expression
on it in order to do that
and that's my next question here
what if any diagnoses did you make of
personality disorders for amber heard
based on your testing i did not make a
personality disorder of misery why not
for a number of reasons
number one a personality disorder
requires a pervasive pattern in a
variety of contexts two key words
pervasive pattern variety of context
that means if her emotional instability
her affect dysregulation or her fear of
abandonment is only occurring in the
relationship with mr depp and we don't
have evidence of it before
and we don't have evidence of it after
it is not our
twitter approach
dr hughes
did
what if anything did dr cowan say to you
about any type of diagnoses
of personality disorders
dr cohen did not diagnose misheard with
any personality disorder and what if
anything did dr bonnie jacobs say about
diagnosing uh amber heard with any
personality disorders and and dr jacobs
similarly did not diagnose ms heard with
any personality disorder thank you
now let's turn back to intimate partner
violence what types of physical violence
were reported to you
um so there were a number of physically
violent behaviors that were reported
that ms heard reported that mr depp
perpetrated
he pushed her he shoved her he slapped
her with the front of his hand and the
back of his hand
he choked her he slammed her into the
wall he pushed her and she fell down
he kicked her in the back
again without looking at my notes that's
what i can recall okay
and what type of injuries did amber
heard report to you
she reported mostly
bruising pain some cuts
she reported vaginal pain from some of
the sexual assaults
she reported that she did have some
scratches and cuts on her from broken
glass
she reported that she believed she may
have lost consciousness two times once
in the australia incident and once in
the december
15 2015 incident
okay
what type of coercive control
did was reported or did you find
leading
sustained
what if any uh
coercive control
was reported to you
so the course of control that um was
determined in this relationship i found
to be quite significant
there were many many instances where
mr deb tried to control
how miss heard went about her career
he didn't want her to show nudity he
didn't wanted her show boob he didn't
want her to act with certain actors
because of this obsessive jealousy
he criticized her ambition
he'd rather she not work he called you
know
the ambition as something as a negative
thing
it made her very fearful to have to look
at scripts or talk about scripts or talk
about movie roles because he
persistently put those down and told her
she didn't need to work and she didn't
need to do that and she didn't need to
show her tits and ass
he didn't necessarily support her work
the way this manifested as well is that
he called
almost every actor that she had to work
with um males and females so no matter
what show she was filming or shooting he
would call the leading actor he would
call the director he would tell you i
got eyes down there i got eyes down on
the set um so she never felt safe to be
herself and be an actress in these films
or productions because she'd have to
come home and then endure his anger at
her for doing something or for not doing
something when she was filming and he
was in the same town she feared that he
would show up on the set and you know to
know what her call she what she was
filming that day she you know even told
her assistant don't give it to him don't
let him see it so that he won't show up
and sometimes he did um so it was very
uh trepidatious for her and very anxiety
provoking that he continued to do this
um he tried to control what she wore
when he
when she was going out with him things
were fine but he told her often no woman
like mine is going to dress like a [ __ ]
and didn't want her to wear revealing
clothing
or revealing clothing according to him
she recalled an incident when she was
going on a job audition and he said you
know you're going to go out with those
tits and ass you know and she had to
sort of go in and and put on what she
said mom jeans so that she didn't look
sexy so she didn't look revealing and
continue to try to plead with him about
what jobs she could take and she could
not take
this made her be very sort of
restrictive and try to conceal things
she would hide her scripts because she
couldn't read them in front of him
because he would put them down or want
to see where there might be nudity where
there might be something where she's
doing a love scene
and then every
almost every person that she was in a
film with there would be those barrages
of the consistent accusations of
infidelity
and we saw that on the australia
pictures the billy bob he was one person
that he continued you know to
berate her about having an affair with
that's what obsessive control looks like
those messages on the mirror um when you
look at how he wanted her to um be there
was some interference with with the
family with her with her sister when her
when some things were leaked you know he
was obsessed believing that it was
whitney who did it and and
eventually miss heard had to succumb and
say okay yes it was and then alienate
herself from her sister because she just
couldn't take the fights anymore she
just couldn't take the constant barrage
of criticism
so there are many instances when
in terms of their interactions of she
would have to text him right back but
when he would text when she would text
him he could not answer for days
um and it's this sort of when we talk
about you know the ghosting but you your
husband doesn't ghost you your partner
doesn't ghost you um and there were so
many times of this sort of withdrawal of
affection which was on his terms and
when he wanted to do it
i'm aware that there is you know
testimony in this case that you know mr
depp decided to leave because he didn't
want to be violent and i do think that's
true sometimes i think he did leave in
times where he didn't want an
altercation he did leave after an
altercation he did leave and then came
back and continued the altercation so
leaving wasn't the defining variable the
problem was that you know with this
obsessiveness and this perseveration
that he had
the fight would always come back so
leaving might end the argument for that
moment
but ms heard no he was always going to
come back and he was going to you know
start the interrogation once again
and what is the effect of the coercive
control on amber heard
i mean the effect was drastic she talked
to me that she you know her roles
consistently dropped over the time that
she was in the relationship with mr depp
just because it was so difficult to go
on auditions to to want to be in in a
different location with him whenever she
was not on location um with him it was
very stressful it was very anxiety
provoking because of the accusations of
infidelity
we heard that through isaac baruch's
testimony when she called and was saying
babe there's no one here there's no one
here that was something that she had to
do repeatedly and constantly over the
course of the relationship so it caused
a significant amount of anxiety of
distress of having to try to conceal and
maneuver around him to to try to have
the career that she wanted to have it
made her hyper vigilant
and definitely contributed to sort of
her psychological symptomatology getting
worse over time
what about sexual violence
so there was a number of incidents of
sexual violence reported um in this
relationship um those are documented
early on in dr bonnie jacobs notes
where when mr depp was drunk or high he
threw her on the bed ripped off her
nightgown and tried to have sex with her
there were times when he forced her to
give him oral sex when he was angry
these weren't in in loving moments these
were angry moments and moments of
dominance moments of him trying to get
control over her
there was a time when they were in
hicksville in in in the trailer i must
say trailer park but i guess there's
trailer park
it is a trailer park um where he was
accusing her of of a woman hitting on
amber and that that was the problem
amber um
got accused of women hitting on her and
it got accused of men hitting on us so
there was there were so many targets
that um
came through in his obsessive jealousy
um but when he um on that incident when
kelly sue um
was accused of hitting on misheard and
they went back into the trailer
mr depp performed a cavity search and
ostensibly was looking for drugs and
felt it acceptable to rip off her
nightgown and and stick his fingers up
her vagina to look for cocaine thought
that maybe she was hiding them there and
again these incidents often happened in
a drug-fueled rage
there was another incident in the
bahamas where when he got angry um he
took his fingers and he put him in her
vagina and moved her around violently in
the closet
again an act of sexual violence
and of course um the incident in in
australia was one of the most severe
instances of sexual violence that um
miss heard had to endure in which when
he was
beating her and choking her and telling
her i'm going to [ __ ] kill you i hate
you i hate you i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you when he grabs a bottle that was on
the bar
and um penetrated her with that bottle
um and miss her reported to me of of
dissociating and going outside of her
body and the only thing she was thinking
is
oh god i hope it's not the broken one
what if any psychological abuse did you
find
um there was a number of psychologically
abusive behaviors as i stated you know
miss heard admitted to me
and reported that she engaged in those
behaviors as well she reported that she
did call him names and offensive
comments and said things to him that
were horrible and that she was
incredibly
saddened and horrified by her behavior
and looking back she at this point not
being in the constant barrage of abuse
does not recognize her
the abuse by mr depp he called her a
number of names um
frequently [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] lesbian camp
counselor um you know easy ambition
ambition was a weaponized term in that
relationship so he called her a lot of
names and humiliated her and of course i
think we talked about the intimidation
tactics that you know mr depp was often
banging and throwing and hitting things
i'm in the household which sort of got
the tension to
rise up very significantly very quickly
can you tell me how you conducted your
analysis to arrive at these conclusions
sure so what i i did was look at the
incidents that were reported
and look at the corroborating data
around it
so as we stated most of these
incidents of intimate partner violence
happen behind closed doors not everyone
is going to witness what the parties are
reporting behind closed doors so you
look at what is the what is the data
that surrounds it is there any data
before it is there any data after it is
the person telling is the victims
telling somebody in real time about
what's happening are there therapy notes
are there pictures are there text
messages that sort of allow us to fill
in the pieces of the picture even though
we don't have exactly what happened at
that moment the more collateral that we
have and the consistency across those
data points it gives us greater
confidence in our results
can can you give us some examples
um sure so
vague
so um for example the boston plane
incident i believe without looking i
know may 24th 2014. this is the incident
where um
miss hurd and mr depp were going to fly
back to la and spend the weekend
together they were shooting at different
sites
miss hurt is on the plane waiting for mr
depp to come on in the tarmac he's
reportedly sitting on the in the suv
smoking and drinking smoking weed and
drinking
she is filming with james franco at this
point and she gets on the plane and he
starts talking about james fanco
you know
making a lot of um
derogatory comments about her and um you
know i hope you had fun with your
escapades and then some more um
inflammatory language and then in
an argument when she got up to leave he
kicked her in the back and she went
forward on the plane
to the front of the plane because he sat
in the back of the plane
so if i look at what is the
corresponding data to this
there's a therapy note several notes in
bonnie jacobs records that talk about
mr depp's increasing use of alcohol
and his obsessive jealousy around james
franco
before this boston plain emphasis
after the incident
miss heard told her friend io
she told a friend savannah she told her
friend rocky
miss heard did not go home she was
afraid to go home so she went to a hotel
because when johnny was in these states
he would often show up
because he's still in that drinking and
drugging phase
and he talked about that that was the
oxycodone before he detoxed you know he
was still in that you know high
substance abuse phase that he would
often show up at night and that did not
feel safe
there was a text from
stephen deuters mr depp's assistant
all right you want to approach
um
all right so
dr hughes
let's go past that text and talk about
um
go past that text and continue after
that text i'm sure so there was um
mr depp apologized to miss her for that
incident um mr depp said in his uk
testimony well i only maybe playfully
tapped her on the back with my foot um
mr depp texted paul bettany and talked
about how he was so drunk and out of
control and engaged in bad behavior he
texted his friend patty smith a very
similar type of text about how drunk and
out of control he was um and then
finally amber heard wrote an email um
talking about how
distressed and heartbroken she was
objection hearsay
i
i i mean i don't agree
sustain i'll sustain the objection next
question all right
can you give can you give another
example
i i think those are all i can um
remember at this point okay
um
what if any uh
what if any um
sorry i'm gonna have to go a little bit
further here so
you concluded that amber heard you
psychological abuse and some reactive
physical violence i think i heard you
say is that correct objection leading
overruled
can you please explain to the jury what
you meant by that yes that is correct
that um you know amber heard reported to
me um some of the behaviors that she
used that were psychologically
aggressive um the name calling the
putting him down and calling him a very
bad names and insulting his his
fatherhood and she was very shamed and
remorseful about that
she also indicated you know using and as
some of the testing showed minor forms
of violence pushing shoving
throwing objects we see that a lot with
women when there's not proportional
force women are more likely to throw
objects
and then the more severe act of of
punching him which a punch falls in the
more severe category and the context
as she explained it was that he was
coming after
whitney and she stood
her sister and she stood in the way and
she punched him
now
does that make
uh amber heard a perpetrator of intimate
partner violence
objection leading
overruled
so so that was one of the tasks that i
had to consider that was one of the
hypotheses that i had to consider and
given all of the other data
that was not my opinion
okay thank you
now you stated that you read a number of
therapy records please tell the jury
why are therapy records important
therapy records are critical for a
forensic psychologist when we have the
opportunity to go back in time and see
what a person was dealing with what the
content of their distress was and what
the symptoms of their distress was it
really gives us a snapshot in time so
they become very critical as part of the
overall forensic psychological
evaluation because we as psychologists
understand how people sort of treat in
therapy and what to look for
so in looking back at
miss herd's therapy records we see sort
of real time unfolding of this dynamic
in this relationship we see early on in
her notes with in her report with bonnie
jacobs and dr bonnie jacobs notes
reports of
constant concerns about mr depp's
substance abuse constant concerns about
him passing out and vomiting constant
concerns about not objection your honor
hearsay
she can characterize that and say she
relied on overruled thank you
please continue
constant concerns about how do i get him
into treatment how do i get him help
miss heard starts going to al-anon at
this point early 2012 and the beginning
of the relationship because she has to
figure out and wants to figure out a way
to support the man that she's dating
right now and the man who she's falling
madly in love with the reports in dr
jacobs notes early on about his
controlling behavior about his jealousy
behavior about him not of not wanting to
do certain jobs of not wanting her to
wear certain clothes so this is going
back to 2012
with no indication of why would she be
saying that but for the sole purpose of
trying to get help and trying to get
guidance in this relationship that she
finds so difficult um there are
indications as i mentioned before of the
sexual assault and the sexual abuse and
and how he would you know when he was
angry and when he was drunk it was
mostly drug and and
alcohol um fueled rage when he would you
know throw her on the bed and try to
have sex with her and then you know if
he was not able to perform he would get
more angry at her and blame her so we
have this dynamic of blaming her for his
inability to take responsibility for his
behavior those themes were throughout dr
jacobs notes
did
um
did dr jacobs assign any diagnoses to
amber heard um she did
early on she diagnosed her with panic
disorder um and then later with
post-traumatic stress disorder all right
and did dr jacobs diagnose amber heard
with borderline personality disorder
no she did not
histrionic personality disorder no she
did not
and is that important
that's very important when we're trying
to figure out the course of somebody's
illness the course of somebody's
psychiatric difficulties as i stated
well i don't think i got to state um
personality disorders usually start in
adolescence early objection
i'll sustain the objection next question
okay
um
you also stated that you reviewed dr
connell cohen's treatment notes correct
correct and you also read his deposition
testimony correct and you had
how long of a collateral interview with
him i believe it was two hours okay
and
what what did you get
from from all of that data
so by the time that she gets to dr
connell cohen which is 2014 i believe
september 2014 is when dr kipper comes
on the scene miss herd's psychological
functioning is significantly
deteriorated she's suffering more
anxiety more sleeplessness more
agitation more emotional dysregulation
this fluctuation in moods and when you
sort of look at the records of what
happened in those first two years from
dr jacobs and now we have up to dr
connell cohen and we see all of the
incidents that she was exposed to
including the sexual violence and the
coercive control it makes sense to me
that her status her psychological
functioning has deteriorated
and in dr
cohen's notes that's what he's
always trying to do he's trying to help
her
help mr depp help her
act in a way so that mr depp does not
hurt her
mr depp i mean pardon me dr connell
cohen was very concerned for
amber heard safety as was dr bonnie
jacobs dr jacobs was very concerned for
her safety and she continued to talk
about safety aspects for ms heard as was
conal cohen um you know they did both of
them both therapists
understood and misheard talk to them
about it that there were times that she
fought back and she used violence and
times that she screamed and she said
things that she didn't want to
but nevertheless that did not change the
balance for them either and they were
very concerned
that because of mr depp's significant
substance abuse and his sort of poorly
controlled anger that at some point he
was going to seriously hurt her
did dr cohen
provide ms heard with a diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder
no he did not did he
diagnose amber heard with histrionic
personality disorder no he did not is
that important
it's important that you are have a an
individual misheard who's in therapy for
over two years with one therapist and
over two years with another therapist
and you're not seeing those
characteristics of a personality
disorder
if the manifestation of a person's
difficulties and illness and
symptomatology is better explained by
another disorder then you don't qualify
for the personality disorder you can't
get the diagnosis i mean that's part of
the criteria so if it's not a pervasive
pattern in a variety of contexts and it
can't be better explained by her trauma
experience and the exposure and the
symptoms as a result of that trauma then
you don't get a personality disorder and
that's why they didn't diagnose it
did you read dr amy banks deposition
testimony yes i did and what were her
findings
so she dr banks had one session um one
couple session with mr depp and miss
heard
dr banks is um
very reputable she works up at the
harvard medical school cambridge victim
the violence program which is a very
well-known program for understanding um
that objection your honor
what's the objection
it's non-responsive to the question
the question was what was the findings
all right
tell us tell the jury who dr amy banks
is and just like i said so she's
somebody who has
a wealth of experience in understanding
intimate partner violence and the
dynamics of of violent relationships but
she only had one session with the couple
and it was her determination when they
were both there and the violence was
talked about that mr depp did not deny
the violence that he um perpetrated
toward misheard um she also did as
everybody has all of her other
therapists because miss hurt admitted as
such that she also used low levels of
violence as well so um dr amy banks had
that opinion
did you review dr laurel anderson's
treatment notes and read her deposition
uh yes i did okay and what was the
significance of
what you learned from dr anderson
so dr anderson similarly thought that
there was violence and abuse in this
relationship she was the one therapist
out of the four who qualified it as
mutual abuse
which
the termination i've talked to you about
i don't necessarily agree with
but she did see and did understand that
there was violence and abuse by mr deb
what was most notable was that after the
december 15th 2015
episode
miss heard called her in addition to
calling conor cohen and reached out to a
number of people but she saw dr anderson
in her office and dr anderson store two
bruises on her face and told me my
husband kicked me and he pushed me and
he punched me in the head and should i
call the police
she's not reading your honor she's just
saying to the significance sustain the
objection next question
all right
what were your uh
what conclusions did you make as a
result of dr
what you reviewed for dr laurel anderson
my
take of
reading dr laurel anderson's deposition
and seeing her you know redacted notes
was that you know
from my professional opinion this was a
very serious incident and a very serious
allegation of intimate partner violence
by mr depp if a patient comes into my
office with two bruises and alleges
being pushed shoved and kicked by her
partner
i'm going to be very concerned and i'm
going to mobilize a lot more resources
to help that individual
and for some reason
that did not happen for miss herd
what are your overall clinical
impressions from reading these notes
from amber herds treatment providers and
their couples therapy therapists
objection compound
sustained
what are your overall clinical
impressions from reading what you told
everybody you read
objection
compound
i i mean i don't know how to get it less
compound your overworld go ahead thank
you
so my overall impression of the the
treatment notes was you know
there's significant support for the fact
that there was intimate partner violence
in this relationship um it was
consistently reported over time
and there were couples therapists who
saw and understood that um so you know
there were
mr deb also attended a session with dr
connell cohen with
misheard
and in that session um he was very
belligerent and mean and yelling and
intimidating and even got up and stormed
out
rolled a joint and then came back later
dr connell cohen's impression was this
is somebody who's poorly controlled
that's the same thing that dr laurel
anderson said about him and he stormed
out of one of those sessions too so
there were a total of six sessions
couple session but mr dep stormed out of
two of them so only four couple sessions
um for these two individuals in this
just highly volatile highly damaging
relationship that was you know
punctuated by the coercive control and
the intimate partner violence
what if any observations did you make
about amber hurd's psychological status
over the that period
i i mean the record was very clear that
her psychological status deteriorated as
she was in the relationship with mr deb
she kept getting worse she was losing
weight she by the end she was down to i
think 105 pounds from about 125 130 she
was taking significantly more medication
than she's ever taken in her life she
was having more panic more anxiety more
distress
more affect this regulation just really
an inability to regulate her mood more
anger outbursts
so it can significantly deteriorate over
time
you talked about weight what if any
diagnoses did
bonnie jacobs make about amber heard
having an eating disorder
there was no evidence in the record that
miss hurt had an eating disorder
what if any observation did you make
about whether dr
cowan connell thought she had an eating
disorder there was no indication in his
record that she had an eating disorder
now
what if any
observations did you make about
the impact of mr deb substance abuse
so the substance abuse was a very
relevant and and complicating factor to
this relationship when you pair that
level of substance abuse with the level
of intimate partner violence and
coercive control it's a very very
disastrous mix and one of the things
that that happens with the substance
abuse is a very similar dynamic that
happens with the intimate partner
violence that there's there's the lying
there's the hiding there's the cheating
there's the
obfuscation you know the rationalization
about the drinking the rationalization
about the violence the trying to you
know promises i'm going to do better i'm
going to get clean and sober i'm not
going to hit you anymore
can i be heard are you approached
right
um
what if any dynamics and coping styles
are connected to the substance abuse by
mr depp
so they share similarities there's a lot
of lying when somebody's a substance
abuser there's a lot of hiding there's a
lot of concealment there's a lot of
rationalization there's a lot of blame
blaming your partner for your inability
to stay clean and sober
there's a lot of the promises to change
and and the promises to get better
so a lot of these dynamics sort of
co-occur you know in a situation of of
substance abuse and domestic violence
they're very similar
the difficulty in this relationship was
that the majority of the violent
episodes and the sexually violent
episodes were in these alcohol and drug
fueled rages that was predominantly when
those happened when
he wasn't in those stages we still saw
the obsessive jealousy and the coercive
control and the possessiveness
that still persisted but when the
alcohol and the drugs came together is
when amber heard was more um in danger
of being hurt by him
why didn't denver heard leave
the relationship
sooner
i mean you know what rejection
speculation
have you formed a
based on your experience and based on
your 29 hours of uh
clinical evaluation of amber heard what
is your understanding of why amber heard
didn't leave the relationship earlier
objection beyond the the scope of the
disclosure
it clearly is not i mean it's clearly in
the disclosure
point point to where you say it's not
i mean where you say it's not
could come forward
now you europe
you indicated that your main opinion was
that amber heard's report of violence
and abuse in her relationship with mr
depp is consistent with what is known as
intimate partner violence
correct
that's correct okay
and and
why did you believe that amber heard
what why did you have what formed your
basis of that opinion
in a nutshell asked and answered your
honor
overall though
the basis of the opinion was looking at
all the dynamics in this relationship
looking at not just the hitting and the
yelling
but looking at how much more hitting was
done looking at the coercive control the
obsessive jealousy the possessiveness
the sexual violence the choking behavior
the threats to kill those are all as i
stated very significant and often found
in cases of lethal domestic violence
those were significant severity factors
and looking at all those um that's what
tipped the scales that even though she
yelled and said some horrible things and
hit him it never was able to shift the
balance of power and control in that
relationship
now you have
discussed with amber hurt and you have
reviewed and evaluated
the emotional impact on amber heard as a
result of emotional distress as a result
of the three counterclaims statements
correctly the three
alleged defamatory statements made by
mr depp through mr waldman correct that
is correct okay objection compound
leading
just over a lot go ahead thank you thank
you could you please tell the jury
what psychological impact these
statements had on amber heard
yes so there were three statements that
i evaluated um
may i
check my notes to give you the dates and
my recollections so that you can i can
be clear since i couldn't put it in this
might be the fastest way your honor i
i'd rather should not address the court
i'm sorry i'm sorry yes okay yes um so
there were three statements on april 8
2020 april 27 2020
and june 24 2020 that i
queried her about and asked her about
the one that
what happens is if somebody who like
misheard has
trauma-based symptoms and ptsd we say
the ptsd is a cube based disorder there
are things that happen in the
environment that trigger it and make it
worse
and having to have to refute
that your report of violence and abuse
is a hoax
makes one the act makes that trauma
activated so it makes the ptsd symptoms
at that time
become more intense and more severe so
she would have more intrusive thoughts
more nightmares more sleeplessness more
difficulty engaging with other people
depression sadness stress
all of that would happen when one of
these statements came out the one that
was you know the most difficult was the
one um where
they um
said that her sexual violence
was a hoax
what's the objection
i think she's going to the to to all
over world injection code
please continue the one that was most
difficult for miss heard was the
statement about calling her sexual
violence a hoax
as i stated earlier
most women try very uh
diligently to
put that sexual violence in a box bury
it down not want to talk about it not
wanna
you know have anything related to it um
come up and you know she's done you know
by my estimation in her coping although
she suffers from post-traumatic stress
disorder she also has a high degree of
coping strategies but when this would
happen it sort of would just everything
would deteriorate um and this is the the
one thing that women are always afraid
of that no one's going to believe them
no one's going to take them seriously
and when somebody comes out in in the
popular media and calls your experience
a hoax
that lended itself to
more severe psychological and traumatic
symptomatology for her
dr hughes are all of your opinions that
you have provided today
within a reasonable degree of
psychological probability or certainty
yes they are
thank you i have no further questions
all right
ladies and gentlemen i think this is a
good time to go ahead and uh break for
the day we can have cross-examination
and redirect tomorrow of this witness of
dr hughes so if you could have a
a good evening do not discuss the case
with anybody and uh
don't do any outside research okay we'll
see you in the morning
thank you
okay
all right dr hugh since you're still in
the middle of your testimony please
don't discuss your testimony with
anybody including the attorneys okay and
anything that you looked at referenced
during your direct examination if you
could just turn that over so they can
review that before cross-examination
okay
all right thank you man
just
i i presume she wants to be able to take
that back with her we can get copies of
it uh we'll get whatever it is okay i'll
i'll we'll make sure you get copies of
it so you make sure you get copies of it
so she can keep her originals yes thank
you all right we have copies of
everything that i don't know
although
no no no no no we're not talking right
now of course
thank you all right so anything else
then so we'll see you tomorrow at 10 a.m
correct all right thank you have a good
evening
oh
you